THIS GUY HEARING. GOING TODAY
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND.
WITH HOLD ON TAKING ROLE FOR FOR
A BIT OF COURSE TODAY IS THE.
HEARING FOCUSED SOLELY ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM BEYOND.
THEY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE CAPTURE
SYSTEM RIGHT NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND. A
FULL TIME.
EQUIVALENT CALIFORNIANS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT AND THEN CERTAINLY A
MANY OF US HAVE A STRONG
FEELINGS TO OUR CSU RATHER. WE
HAVE WHEN OUR DISTRICT JURY OR
YOU WENT TO A CSU SO THAT'S
CERTAINLY HOW MY CASE.
YOU KNOW THE.
THE CSU SYSTEM YOU KNOW HAD ITS
UPS AND DOWNS DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION BUT YOU KNOW POLICE
TO.
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO MAKE SOME SIGNIFICANT THREE
INVESTMENTS IN THEM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM HELPING
STABILIZE FUNDING. AND THAT
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND
ACCESS BUT WE KNOW THAT'S. NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH WE HAVE CERTAINLY
A LONG WAYS TO GO WILL BE
HEARING ABOUT. THAT DURING
TODAY'S AYE TODAY'S HEARING.
WE ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON ON SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE KNOW
EXISTS I KNOW EVEN WITH. OUR
STABLE FUNDING THE PAST FEW
YEARS WE WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO.
ACCOMMODATE EVERY CALIFORNIAN
WHO'S ELIGIBLE APPLIES THIS
YEAR'S YOU WE ESTIMATE IS ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND.
QUALIFIED STUDENTS ARE TURNED
AWAY EACH YEAR AND THAT CRISIS
OF ACCESS IS SOMETHING THAT
CONCERNS US WORKING TO. AYE
RESOLVE WE ALSO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THEIR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
I KNOW WE HAVE GOT CAMPUS
PRESENT HERE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
EFFORTS HERE IN IN SACRAMENTO.
IT CERTAINLY ADDRESSING THIS
WOULD HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE IN
THEM. MORE UPRIGHT PROMPTED A
TIME PERIOD THE LESSENING THE
BURDENS ON DEBT INSTANT LOANS
AND SO FORTH BUT ALSO.
FREEING UP SPACE RATHER
CALIFORNIANS TO HELP US
ACCOMMODATE THOSE THIRTY
THOUSAND WHO DON'T HAVE. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND THE S. CSU
SYSTEM AYE WE KNOW THAT THE
JANUARY BUDGET.
WE'RE GONNA HEAR IS.
WAS A.
.
WAS NOT QUITE WHAT THE CSU
SYSTEM AND THE TRUSTEES ASK FOR
IN THEIR REQUEST AND SO WE WANT
TO HEAR MORE. ABOUT THAT WHAT
ENTAILS ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON
WHAT.
ELEMENTS ARE THERE IN THAT
REQUESTS AND I KNOW IT'S A
HUNDRED. AND SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
SOMEONE OF CONCERN OF THIS A
SUBCOMMITTEE IS THAT.
SUCH A LIMITED AMOUNT GOES TO
ACCESS
AND.
FULFILLING ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FOR CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE WE GO
HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS ASK US ABOUT
ACCESS NOT CORPS NEEDS NOT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NOT
COMPENSATION. THAT THE OTHERS
THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT ISSUES
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE CERTAINLY
HERE. FROM OUR HOME IN OUR
DISTRICTS
SO THAT'S KIND OF A. SNAPSHOT OF
OVER LOOKING AT TALKING ABOUT
TODAY SO THAT. NOW LET'S GET
GOING AND BRING UP CSU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE LA
O. TO GO OVER THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY BUDGET.
SO ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS THE
GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSED.
BUDGET AS WELL AS THE CSU
FUNDING REQUEST WILL START OFF
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE LA GO AND
THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM.
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
DAN HAD OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THIS CSU SERVES OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES.
AT THE CSU RECEIVESFUNDING FROM
A VARIETY OF SOURCES INCLUDING
STATE GENERAL FUND FEDERAL FUNDS
STATE LOTTERY FUND.
AND STUDENT TUITION AND FEES.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
NINETY YEAH A BUDGET INCREASE OF
NINETY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT.
THIS IS COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT
THE UC FOUR RECEIVER AS IN
KEEPING WITH PAST PRACTICE.
.
THIS WILL PROVIDE THE CSU WITH.
JUST OVER THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
WELL THE CSU IS THE AUTONOMY TO
USE THESE FUNDS AS THEY BEST SEE
FIT.
THE ADMINISTRATION HOPES AT
THESE FUNDS WILL GO TOWARDS
FURTHERING THE EFFORTS OF THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES THIRTY NINE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
ONGOING SUPPORT.
FOR RETIREMENT RATE ADJUSTMENT.
AND WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
ALEJO'S.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY PAUL
STEINHAUSEN WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AS YOU JUST HEARD THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES A NINETY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. DOLLAR UNRESTRICTED
GENERAL FUND PACING CREASED FOR
CS YOU WHICH IS THE SAME DOLLAR
AMOUNT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES FOR
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU'LL HEAR THAT MUCH MORE
NOW WHEN.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY A PRESENTS
US YES YOU WOULD LIKE MUCH MORE
THAN THAT A CS USE ASKING FOR A
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR.
INCREASING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
AND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS MORE WHEN
INCLUDING SOME OTHER RESOURCES.
SO CSU IS ASKING FOR
CONSIDERABLY MORE THAN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING.
AND THE TABLE ON PAGE FOUR OF
YOUR AGENDA SUMMARIZES CS USE
FUNDING REQUEST.
AS WITH ANY OTHER YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE FACES TWO
FUNDAMENTAL DECISIONS WITH CS
USE BUDGET. FIRST WHICH COST
INCREASES
SUPPORT.
AND THEN AFTER CALCULATING THE
PRICE TAG
FOR THOSE
ACOSTA INCREASES YOU WANT TO
SUPPORT DECIDE.
HOW?
THOSE COSTS WILL BE SHARED
BETWEEN THE STATE. AND STUDENTS.
YOU COULD.
I HAVE THE STATE THE GENERAL
FUND BEAR THE FULL FACT OF THESE
COST INCREASES OR ALTERNATIVELY
YOU COULD HAVE NON FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. A A PAY A SHARE OF THE
COST
I SAY NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF COURSE
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS GET.
A TUITION COVERAGE.
THE GENDER DOES A NICE JOB
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THE MAJOR
COST PRESSURES
THAT YOU MAY CHOOSE TO FIND AND.
CHAIR MCCARTY YOU MENTIONED
ACCESS.
AND ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS TO STUDENTS
AND THE STATE WITNESS THIS BODY.
WHAT THE? WHAT CSU IS PROPOSING
FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS
RELATIVELY SMALL COMPARED TO THE
OVERALL SYSTEM WIDE REQUESTED
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS BUT? FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S.
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT ARE
COST COMPONENT FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER.
IN RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
AND THE CSU HAS A NUMBER OF
ENROLLMENT PRESSURES AND
CONSIDERATIONS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR RELATED TO ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
.
ONE ONE CONSIDERATION.
IS THAT THE NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES
IN THE STATE.
IS EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY
ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT PERCENT
THIS YEAR INSP IN THE SPRING.
WHICH ALL OTHER THINGS BEING
EQUAL WOULD RESULT IN AN
INCREASE OF DEMAND OF ONE POINT
EIGHT PERCENT.
FOR FALL FOR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ARE IN ENROLLMENT YOU HAVE THE
STUDENTS. COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL OF WANTING A SLOT AT NOT
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY.
JERRY MCCARTY ALSO MENTION THE
ISSUE OF STUDENTS THAT HAVE
APPLIED TO CSU AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE uGET
BE THE ONLY ONE. APPLY TO ONE
PROGRAM THAT ONE CAN'T THIS OR
MAYBE THEY APPLY TO MULTIPLE
CAMPUSES BUT THERE'S ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS EACH
YEAR. THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
INTO ANY PROGRAM THAT CSU THEY
APPLY TO WIN AND THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT. LATER IN THE
AGENDA.
AND UNDERLYING ISSUE AN ISSUE
THAT UNDERLIES THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ENROLLMENT AT
CS YOU IS THE FACT THAT CSU IS
DRAWING FROM WELL BEYOND ITS
MASTER PLAN. TARGET LEVEL.
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT THAT MEANS
IS IN THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CSU LEARNED THAT ITS
ADMISSIONS POLICIES
ARE IDENTIFYING THE TOP FORTY
ONE PERCENT. OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES AS ELIGIBLE TO ATTEND
CSU IS FRESHMAN THE TOP FORTY
ONE PERCENT RATHER THAN THE TOP
THIRTY THREE PERCENT WHICH IS
BEEN THE STATE'S HISTORIC
PRACTICE.
SO.
THIS MEANS THAT CSU IS DEEMING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AS ELIGIBLE FOR FRESH
IN IT FRESHMAN ADMISSION WHEN
HISTORICALLY. THE STUDENTS WOULD
HAVE BEEN. AYE DIVERTED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FIRST TO
COMPLETE THEIR FRESHMAN AND
SOPHOMORE YEARS AND THEN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO TRANSFER TO CSU
ACTUALLY GUARANTEED TO TRANSFER
TO SEE IF YOU IF THEY GET A
CERTAIN GPA.%
SO THIS ISSUE ABOUT CSU FINDING
IT'S DRYING FROM BEYOND ITS
MASTER PLAN TARGET LEVEL. IS
REALLY CREATED A LOT OF EN ROUTE
ROMAN PRESSURE ON THE SYSTEM AND
GOING FORWARD THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A DECISION TO MAKE ON.
WHETHER CSU SHOULD BE PERMITTED
TO CONTINUE DRAWING FROM THIS
LARGER POOL OF STUDENTS.
OR WHETHER OUR CS YOU SHOULD BE
ARE COUNSELED TO TIGHTEN ITS
ADMISSION.
CRITERIA SO THAT IT GETS BACK
DOWN TO.
MAYBE THIRTY THREE PERCENT OR
WHATEVER LEVEL YOU TEAM IS.
IS IS NEEDED IS IS PREFERABLE IS
COST EFFECTIVE FOR THE STATE AND
THE SYSTEM.
HADN'T NOW ADOPTING STRICTER
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS WOULD
REDUCE THOSE ENROLLMENT
PRESSURES ON CSU IN THE OUT.
YEARS AND FREE UP GENERAL FUND
FOR OTHER COST OF. PURPOSES
OTHER UP PRIORITIES ON THE OTHER
HAND IT WOULD MEAN THAT OTHER
THAT MORE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
ARE COMING OUT NO GRADUATING
THEIR SENIOR YEAR WITH A THREE
POINT NO OR HIGHER.
MIGHT FIND THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
TO GO TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES
FIRST AND SO THAT COULD LEAD TO
SOME.
DISAPPOINTMENT OR FRUSTRATION
ON THEIR PART MAY NOT BE THEIR
FIRST. CHOICE SO YOU JUST HAVE
TO WEIGH THOSE KINDS OF TRADE
OFFS.
YEAH SO REALLY IN SOME ON THIS
ENROLLMENT ISSUE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO NEED TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT UNDERLYING DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES THAT ONE POINT EIGHT
PERCENT INCREASE I MENTIONED
EARLIER. INCREASE IN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADS THIS YEAR I TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THIS ISSUE OF IMPACTION.
AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE STATE POLICY ON WHICH
STUDENTS COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL ARE ELIGIBLE TO ENROLL
DIRECTLY AT CSU.
SO AND THEN ISSUE TO THIS AGENDA
IS GONNA GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
OTHER MAJOR ISSUES ISSUE TOO
COURSES GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE WHICH IS
ANOTHER AND A. BIG TICKET ITEM
AND AND PRIORITY OF THE CSU.
MR STARR.
I THINK YOU A CHAIR MCCARTY
MUNNINGS RAINSTORM ON THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL
AGAIN.
MY COMMENTS WILL BE VERY
SIMILAR TO THAT OVERVIEW HEARING
BACK IN FEBRUARY.
BECAUSE THE C. ISSUES ESSENTIAL.
OF FUN PER PRIORITIES HAVE NOT
CHANGED SINCE THEN.
IT WILL DO IS I LIKE TO START
WITH AN ASSERTION ON I HOPE YOU
HOPE YOU AGREE WITH THIS I
THINK.
MOST OF YOU HAVE HEARD MANY OF
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR.
AND YOUR PREFERENCES OVER THE
YEARS AND I LIKE TO MAKE THIS
ASSERTION TO SEE ISSUE AND YOU
ASSURE THE SAME FUNDING
PRIORITIES.
THEY ARE IMPROVING GRADUATION
RATES.
THERE INCREASING STUDENT ACCESS.
AND THEY ARE FAIRLY COMPENSATING
OUR EMPLOYEES.
SO THESE PARTIES HAVE BEEN IN
CURRENTLY ARE IN OUR WILL AND
WILL BE OUR SHARE PARTY'S GOING
FORWARD.
YOU KNOW REVISIT THESE PARTIES.
THROUGHOUT MY COMMENTS.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK FIRST AT
HOW THESE PARTIES HAVE SOME HAVE
BEEN SUPPORT IN THE RECENT PAST.
IF YOU TAKE A STAND OUT HERE.
HAD THE SURGEON HAD THAT OUT
YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO. LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU AGAIN THE MANY
CSU SUCCESSES SINCE THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY BEGAN.
CHAIR MCCARTY MENTION THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOOD
INVESTMENT THE C. ISSUE.
SINCE THE AVERAGE RECOVERY AND
WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF IT FOR
SURE. AND IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
ALL THE SUCCESSES THAT YOU SEE
ON THIS LIST HERE TODAY WITHOUT.
YOUR REGULAR INVESTMENT AS WELL
AS THE SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR.
.
SO YOUR PARTNERSHIP OVER IT.
WITH THIS ISSUE OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS HAS RESULTED IN IN
THESE ACHIEVEMENTS HERE AND A
HIGH LIKE THREE OF THEM WE COULD
SEE THEM HERE CHECKED IN BLUE.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ENROLL A
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND MORE A FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS THAT'S
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND HEAD
COUNT FUNDED HEAD COUNT.
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO CREATING
TWO NEW CAMPUSES.
AT ESSENTIALLY ONE THE SIZE OF
CSU SAN BERNADINE ON THE OTHER
THE SIZE OF CHICO STATE.
CAMPUSES OF HAVE ALSO ADDED AN
ESTIMATED FIFTEEN THOUSAND NEW
COURSE SECTIONS.
TO THEIR OFFERINGS.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED MORE.
IN JUST THE LAST YEAR ALONE
USING THE GRADUATION ISSUED A
FUNDING.
AND WE'VE CONSISTENTLY A CIVIL
EMPLOYEE CONTRACTS OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH ROOM BRIEFLY AT THE
C. ISSUE NOW LET'S TURN TO
TODAY.
SO ORDER PROVIDE SOME HIGH LEVEL
CONTEXT. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
THREE. THE SHOWS THE MAIN
REVENUE SOURCES FOR THE CSU
OPERATING BUDGET.
AND.
ABOUT HALF OF THE A HALF OF
THAT FUNDING IS FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND. AND THE OTHER HALF
IS FROM TUITION AND FEES.
AND THIS EXCLUDES THOSE REVENUE
SOURCES LIKE HOUSING.
PARKING A CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND OTHER ENTERPRISE WILL BE
CALL ENTERPRISE ACTIVITIES
SO THOSE THINGS ARE CAN A
WRAPAROUND ACTIVITIES AND AND
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ON TALKING UP HERE
ON THIS PARTICULAR SLIDE JUST
ABOUT OUR OP. BUDGET.
WHAT IS WHAT YOU SIMMERS
SIMILARLY SEE ON THE UC SIDE TO
CALL THEIR CORE BUDGET THIS IS
KIND OF AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON TO THAT?
BUT PAGE FOUR SHOWS THE MAIN
CATEGORIES OF EXPENSES FOR THE
OPERATING BUDGET.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE SEIZURES
PREDOMINATELY A PEOPLE POWERED
UNIVERSITY.
ABOUT SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR
EXPENSES ARE FOR THE SALARIES
AND WAGES OF OUR APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
ADDITIONALLY WORTH NOTING IS
THAT INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID
WHAT WE CALL THE STATE
UNIVERSITY GRANT. TOTALS ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSIST ABOUT ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH THEIR
TUITION COSTS.
I STILL FOCUSING ON TODAY AT
PAGE FIVE IS WHERE WILL CAMP OUT
FOR IT A LITTLE BIT.
.
IN THIS HANDOUT SERVES A A
COUPLE PURPOSES.
ONE OF THOSE PURPOSES IS TO TO.
DIPPED DEPICT OUR SHARED
PARTIES TODAY.
AS REFLECTED IN THE C. ISSUES
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE RIGHT COLUMN THAT YOU SEE IS
THE TRUSTEES REQUEST INCREASE OF
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S THE AMOUNT THAT.
I MISTER STEVE HAS MENTIONED
EARLIER.
THAT'S DEFINED ONLY WHAT WE
WOULD SAY ARE MOST ESSENTIAL
ITEMS.
WHICH INCLUDE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FAIR COMPENSATION
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS AS WELL AS A MANDATORY
COST LIKE HEALTH AND RETIREMENT
COST INCREASES.
SO WE'VE AND WE HAVE A GREAT
MOMENTUM IN OUR TRIP IN OUR AND
ARE ON TRACK TO MAKE S. HISTORIC
PROGRESS ON DOUBLING OUR FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATES.
THROUGH THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TO HEAR A LOT ABOUT
THAT IN THE NEXT PANEL.
BUT WE WILL NEED ONGOING AND
CONSISTENT.
IN ENHANCE FUNDING TO REALIZE
GOALS OVER.
THE NEXT STEP FIVE YEARS
INCLUDING OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YEAR.
IN THIS THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS
MEET MINIMUM CSU ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND COMPLETE THEIR
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
DEGREES AT THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
WE NEED RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN OFFER THEM A SEAT AT THE
CSU.
AND YOU'LL BE DEALING WITH A LOT
ALL IS ENROLLMENT DISCUSSIONS
AND TOPICS OF LATER THAT MISTER
STEVE HOUSE AND ALSO MENTIONED
SO. YOU HAVE THAT LATER ON YOUR
AGENDA AS WELL.
ALSO AFTER YEARS OF STAGNANT
WAGES I DO THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION.
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF ARE
RECEIVING WELL DESERVED RAISES.
ON AVERAGE ABOUT THREE PERCENT
PER YEAR.
COMPARABLE TO THOSE RECEIVED BY
STATE EMPLOYEES.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE HEALTH CARE AND
PENSION COST INCREASES REQUIRE
CONSTANT FISCAL ATTENTION EACH
AND EVERY YEAR.
I KNOW THE OTHER PURPOSE OF THIS
PAGE IS TO BEGIN TO ANSWER THAT
COMMONLY ASKED QUESTION NAMELY
WHAT ARE SEE ISSUES THOUGHTS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDES AS YOU HEARD FROM.
MISTER HAN OUR AYE NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT PROVIDES A
ONE POINT FOUR PERCENT INCREASE
TO OUR TOTAL OPERATING BUDGET.
THOSE TO PIE CHARTS THAT I
SHOWED YOU EARLIER. THAT FALLS
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILLION
SHORT OF OUR OF FUNDING REQUEST.
NO THE LEFT COLUMN SHOWS HOW FAR
WE CAN STRETCH THAT NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
WHEN MEASURED AGAINST THE IN
THAT THE UNIVERSE IS ENTIRE
OPREME BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INCREASE PROVIDES LESS
THAN HALF THE RATE OF INFLATION.
AND THE SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. IT'S SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS SHORT OF WHAT WE NEED
SIMPLY TO COVER OUR EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION BECAUSE.
AND ARE MANDATORY COST
INCREASES.
YOU CAN SEE THE SIXTY ONE
MILLION AT DEPICTED HERE IN
THOSE HASH REDLINES.
SO WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
IT WILL BE A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR
FOR US FRANKLY.
IN CAMPUS PRESENCE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS TO
COVER FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS
RESULTING IN DECREASES A CAMPUS
OPERATIONS INCLUDING ACADEMIC.
PROGRAMS AND ACADEMIC SUPPORTS.
ALSO.
THE TRUSTEES WILL HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO AUTHORIZE A
TUITION INCREASE TO MEET VERY
BASIC FINANCIAL NEEDS OF OUR
CAMPUSES.
AND TO BE MORE PRECISE A TUITION
INCREASES AN OPTION OF LAST
RESORT FOR THE C. ISSUE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE NAY THAT
POSSIBLE ARE THE POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE IT BUDGETS ARE TODAY WE
WOULD NOT A SET US UP. NOW AND
SET US UP NOR STUDENTS ARE THE
STATE'S ECONOMY FOR A STELLAR A
TOMORROW.
WITH NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EARNING
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES IN THE CSU
EVERY YEAR AT A TIME WHEN THE
STATE HAS A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS.
I I KNOW WHETHER I INVESTMENT
HAS THE SAME POTENTIAL TO
POSITIVELY IMPACT
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE.
SO I THINK PAGE SIX SUMS IT UP.
I TO SEE ISSUE IN THE STATE
ENSURE.
COMMENT PARTIES TODAY.
THAT WILL SHAPE TOMORROW.
SO CAN FIT CONSISTENT INVESTMENT
IN COMPLETION THROUGH THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE CONSISTS
INVESTMENT IN IN ENROLLMENT AND
NEW ACCESS.
AND CONSISTENT INVESTMENT AND
MOMENTUM THROUGH OUR REGULAR
COMPENSATION INCREASES AND OTHER
NECESSITIES.
THOSE THREE PARTIES WILL HELP
MEET CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE GOOD
PROGRESS SO FAR AND WE HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUE THE MOMENTUM OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS.
AND WE THIS YEAR'S YOU CAN.
THAT CAN ONLY ACCOMPLISH THESE
PARTIES WITH YOUR FINANCIAL
PARTNERSHIP.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR
FUNDING OF THIS ISSUES BUDGET
REQUEST.
BY INVESTING ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU IN ARE OPEN TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU WE WILL HAVE THAT
SERIES OF QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
HERE BUT LET'S TAKE ROLE WILL.
MCCARTY HERE.
CHáVEZ HERE.
MEDINA HERE.
MURATSUCHI.
CORMAN'S ESTABLISHED.
THANK YOU WILL START WITH THE MR
MEDINA.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
THAT THAT CSU TURNS AWAY.
YOU MENTIONED A INCREASE OF
DEMAND IN THE NEXT YEAR OF ONE
POINT EIGHT PERCENT STUDENT
DEMAND.
FRUIT SEE ISSUE CAN YOU
TRANSLATE THAT INTO NUMBERS.
FOR ME.
ONE POINT EIGHT PERCENT WOULD BE
ABOUT.
EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
WHAT A SIX? YEAR TERMS IT REACTS
OR STUDENTS ANSWERS ACTUAL
STUDENTS WRITE ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND BUT IT DOES DOES IT OF
THIS.
OKAY.
JEFF JARVIS.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS
DISCUSSION SO I'M GLAD YOU'RE
HERE.
.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES WE WE
HEAR ABOUT IN CALIFORNIA. A LOT
WHICH WHICH NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
AS A WHOLE ISSUES SOCIAL EQUITY.
AND THE ABILITY TO.
OBTAIN THAT.
ESPECIALLY IN A CHALLENGING
COMMUNITIES ENSURE THAT.
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE A GOOD
EDUCATION BECAUSE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE GOOD EDUCATION THEN
THEY GET THE JOB TO GO FORWARD.
AND WE KNOW THAT.
THE A CHANGING SOCIETY THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
.
PEOPLE NEED MORE SKILLS TO BE
COMPETITIVE INTERNATIONALLY.
SO.
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH SOME THE
COMMENT YOU MADE.
AND.
AND THEN TYING TO I THINK WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS GO.
THE HIGH SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATE INCLUDES ANA
IMPROVING THE ONE POINT EIGHT.
DOES I'M LIKE A BIG NUMBER TO
ME.
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S STANDPOINT
IS THAT AN APPROPRIATE NUMBER IS
A GOOD NUMBER.
SHOULD WE BE DOING BETTER.
THE ONE POINT EIGHT PERCENT
INCREASE DEMAND NOT GRADUATION
LABELS I SCHOOL GRADUATIONS
APPROVED BY ONE POINT EIGHT IS
THAT A GOOD NUMBER BAD NUMBER
SHOULD BE HIGHER LOWER.
CHRIS FORGET SOME OF FINANCE.
I THINK I'D HAVE TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT COVER THAT THE
CAPABLE SECTION OF OUR BUDGET
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO. ARMED RESPONSE
YOUR QUESTION AFTER HE SAID THAT
BUT WHAT I WANT WHEN I'M TRYING
TO HIGHLIGHT THE POINT IS THAT.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM CALIFORNIA
WITH CASEY TWELVE GRADUATION
RATE.
AND THAT IN BILLS LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION WAS STUDENTS WHICH I'M
A BIG SUPPORTER OF. BUT IS ALSO
A.
BIG REQUIREMENT FOR CHILDREN
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE GOING TO
COLLEGE BE COLLEGE READY.
NOW WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT.
THE ALLEY ó TALKED ABOUT THE
MASTER PLAN BEING AT THIRTY
THREE PERCENT OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WOULD BE GOING OFF TO.
COLLEGE WERE AT FORTY ONE
PERCENT.
.
FROM A LA O. PERSPECTIVE LOOKING
AT THE ECONOMY HAS.
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO GROW OUR WORKFORCE.
IS FORTY ONE PERCENT TO GOOD
NUMBER.
FORGETTING ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
THE MASTER PLAN BEING AT THIRTY
THREE PERCENT.
IS FORTY ONE PERCENT THE RIGHT
NUMBER FOR OUR SOCIETY TO GO
FORWARD SHOULD BE FORTY FIVE
FIFTY OR SHOULD ITBE TWENTY
FIVE.
I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS THE GROWTH.
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT.
FROM MINNELLI O. PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT.
TO LAND ON BUT COUPLE THINGS WE
DO. A.
LIKE TO TO THINK ABOUT AND AND
SHARE.
FIRST IT'S IMPORTANT TO JUST.
ARE.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE WHETHER
IT'S THIRTY THREE PERCENT OR
FORTY ONE PERCENT
OF THE OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
GOING TO YEAH ELIGIBLE TO ATTEND
CSU THAT'S JUST AS FRESHMEN THAT
THAT. THE MASTER PLAN.
TALKED ABOUT UNIVERSAL ACCESS
TO A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
THROUGH ONE OF TWO ROUTES.
THAT PREFERENCE IN THE MASTER
PLAN IS FOR THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS.
FIRST ATTEND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND THEN TRANSFER TO CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY YOUR YOU SEE. OR A
PRIVATE
YEAH AND THAT'S THAT'S A COST IS
IS A LOT BEHIND THAT YOU TO KEEP
COSTS DOWN KEPT A COMMITTEE
COLLEGES HAVE LOWER. OPERATING
COSTS THEN YOU SEE INSIDIOUS YOU
YOU SEE FOCUSES ON RESEARCH CSU
HAS RESEARCH AS WELL AND AND A
LOT OF UPPER DIVISION STUDENTS
IT'S A MORE EXPENSIVE SYSTEM. SO
THE IDEA OF IN THE MASTER PLAN
IS TO HAVE THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS GO TO. OUR COMMITTEE
COLLEGES FIRST TO DO THEIR LOWER
DIVISION COURSEWORK AND THEN GO
TO UC AND CSU. YEAH IDEA THERE
IS IF.
IF THE STATE CAN.
REDUCE COSTS AT THE LOWER
DIVISION LEVEL THEY'LL BE MORE
MONEY FOR THE STUDENTS WHEN THEY
ARRIVE AS TRANSFER STUDENTS.
SO. THE FIRST POINT IS ABOUT
TRANSFER YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS IS
DOESN'T MEAN THAT ONLY THIRTY
THREE PERCENT OF STUDENTS ARE
FORTY ONE PERSON STUDENTS HAVE A
CHANCE TO GO TO.
CS YOU IT JUST MEANS THEY HAVE
TO GO TO A CHANCE TO GO TO CSU
AS FRESHMEN
AND IN FACT.
IT'S ABOUT HALF I THINK GIVE CSU
STUDENTS ARE. A GRADUATES OF THE
CSU A BACHELORS DEGREE PROGRAM
STARTED THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE OTHER ISSUE FOR YOU TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION IS THE COST
THE COST ISSUE YOU HAVE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. THAT
IS.
AUTOMATICALLY SPENT ON K. TWELVE
INCOMMUNICADO EDGES YOU HAVE SO
SPACE AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES LOT
OF COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY HAVE ON USED ENROLLMENT.
CAPACITY.
AND SO.
AND AT SAME TIME CSU IS A MORE
EXPENSIVE SYSTEM BY VIRTUE OF
THE FACT THAT IT SERVING UPPER
DIVISION STUDENTS AND DOES HAVE.
IN.
GRADUATE STUDENTS AS WELL SO
JUST TAKEN DO JUST THAT WE
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATORS TO REALLY
WAY THAT THAT ISSUE ABOUT COST
AS WELL. A WHEN DECIDING ON AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL.
LET'S GO TO THE ISSUE OF COST.
YOU LOOK LIKE A DISEASE USE I
MEAN TO COMEDIC ALL JUST.
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE HAD
A HEARING A FEW WEEKS AGO
TALKING ABOUT MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT THROUGH.
THE INTERNET
ONLINE TO AND WE HAD ADDS BIG
PUSH BACK AGAINST.
.
WHAT PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS TO
GO IN THE COMMUNICABLE EDGES ARE
GIVEN THE SKILLS? ACTUALLY
TRANSFERRED TO IS CSU.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
STILL MANY COLLEGE YOU NEED
COLLEGE ACTUALLY TRANSFER
INDICES YOU?
I'M NOT SURE I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT ARE VERY HIGH
PROBABLY ABOUT IF YOU LOOK AT.
STUDENTS THAT ARE.
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES AS
WANTING TO TRANSFER IT'S FIFTY
PERCENT ARE UNDER GETS US ABOUT
A BIG DUMB AND SO MY POINT IS
AND BACK IN THE DAY WHEN I WAS
WENT TO COMMUNICABLE AGE. IT WAS
A MUCH LARGER NUMBER.
AND WOULDN'T ANOTHER INTERESTING
THING WE HEARD JUST A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHEN ANOTHER SUB
BUDGET DO WEARING.
THAT.
.
WHEN YOU TRANSFERRED.
TWO A KIT BAG SHE ISSUE ALL YOUR
CLASSES WERE NOT IMMEDIATELY
ACCEPTED BY THE SEA AS YOU.
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT WHILE YOUR
ENGLISH TWO HUNDRED.
AT YOU KNOW JUNIOR COLLEGE. DE
IS ADOPTED STANDARD OF MY.
ENGLISH TWO HUNDRED AT.
YOU KNOW CA ISSUE A. B. C. D..
AND.
IN THERE WAS THIS WHOLE US DISC
ISSUE OF AN ALIGNMENT
SO THAT CLASS AGO SO HOW WE
DOING THIS ALIGNMENT WE HAD THAT
HEARING ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO
FOUR YEARS AGO. AND WE IMPROVE
THAT.
A LINE IT HAS LOST ITS UNITS A
COST ISSUE IT IS ALIGNMENT HAS
IMPROVED
IN LARGE PART DUE TO.
A.
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS
ARE CREATING ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFERS THAT WAS A BIG
STEP FORWARD.
AND ARE A LOT OF WORK OF FACULTY
AT THE COMMUNICABLE EDGES AND
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY ARE COMING
TOGETHER AND CREATING A COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM. AND
DEVELOPING A.
MODEL CURRICULUM FOR VARIOUS
SUBJECT AREAS.
SO IT HAS IMPROVED.
IT'S GOTTEN BETTER THE STATE
HAS INVESTED A LOT OF.
TIME AND MONEY.
INTO IMPROVING THE THE TRANSFER
PATHWAY HOW MUCH BETTER FIFTY
PERCENT SAID FIVE PERCENT.
TWENTY PERCENT.
GIVE ME IF FILL.
I DON'T THINK I'D I HAVE A.
SENATE MIND I I THINK IT'S IN.
I THINK IT'S IMPROVED
CONSIDERABLY I WOULD SAY IF THAT
HELPS I THINK IT'S IMPROVE
CONSIDERABLY FOR STUDENTS.
BUT THERE'S STILL A WAYS TO GO.
WE'VE WRITTEN OUR OFFICE IS
WRITTEN ABOUT THE ISSUE OF.
STUDENTS GRADUATING WITH AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFERRED
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AND THEN THAT.
DEGREE.
I OR THAT THE CONCENTRATION WITH
THAT WITHIN THAT DEGREE IS NOT
CONSIDERED SENATOR.
SIMILAR.
BY THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS AND SO FOR THAT STUDENT.
TACTIC READ IS NOT GIVE THEM A
GUARANTEE AND AND AND TO TO TO
GET OUT AND SIXTY MORE UPPER
DIVISION UNITS WHAT AND ONE TOLL
GRIPPED HIM FOR THE DRAGON HERE
YOU GUYS WANT TO GET OUT HERE.
BUT DE WHAT I LIKE TO DO IS.
COME SEE ME BECAUSE WHEN I HEAR
PEOPLE TELL ME ALL ITS
CONSIDERABLE IMPROVEMENT MY
LITTLE BRAIN TELLS ME. THAT IS
PROBABLY NOT AS MUCH AS I WANT
IN SO IT'S THAT'S A SOFT NUMBER.
SOMEONE AND KNOW WHAT IT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING BUDGET
MONEY ELLIS GO THIS YEAR'S SHOES
IF YOU DECIDE TO TRANSFER FROM
ONE SEE ISSUED ANOTHER SERIOUS
YOU. FOR WHATEVER REASON.
HOW EASY TRANSFER RATE BETWEEN
CSU TO SEE ISSUE? MAYBE I COULD
ASK THE.
FASTER SO WELL THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE MIGHT BETTER BE ABLE TO
ANSWER IT LATER ON ON THE IN THE
THIRD PANEL.
WE HAVE A AND REALLY MANAGEMENT
EXPERT WITH THIS IS A MONEY
ISSUE THOUGH.
WELL.
.
FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT BETWEEN
SEE ISSUES THAT WOULD BE A ZERO
SUM GAME I MEAN WHAT WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE IT YOU'D HAVE ONE
STUDENT. A LEAVING A PARTICULAR
SPOT OPEN ON THE CAMPUS AT THE
TRANSFERRING FROM.
MOVING TO ANOTHER CAMPUS THAT
HAS AN OPEN.
ENROLLMENT SLOT SO REALLY TO
ZERO SUM GAME BETWEEN THE
CAMPUSES SO. I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S ANY SORT OF COST SAVINGS
IF THERE'S A TRANSFER OF DEATH
ONE SKIN FROM MY NOTES SAY HERE
THAT. IF YOU REDUCE THE AMOUNT A
UNITS OF THE STUDENT HAS TO
TAKE.
MY WILL BY NO ONE.
BECAUSE THEY WAS ABLE TO
TRANSFER SO I DIDN'T HAVE TO
TAKE.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE UNITS I
ONLY TAKE HUNDRED TWENTY TO GET
A DEGREE. I WOULD SAY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
FUNDING.
WELL ON THAT FRONT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF UNITS IN ORDER TO GRADUATE
FROM A C. ISSUE OTHER REYES
LAUGHING BEHIND YOU RIGHT NOW SO
GO AHEAD WEALTH OF ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO POINT
OUT WITHOUT IS THAT STARTING
MANY YEARS AGO.
WE TOOK OF A REAL CLOSE LOOK AT
ALL OF OUR DEGREES TO SEE HOW
MANY OF THEM WERE IN EXCESS OF
WHAT THE TYPICAL HUNDRED TWENTY
UNITS IN ORDER TO GRADUATE.
THINK THAT TIME THE NUMBER WAS
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
OUR KEY OF OUR. OF OUR DEGREES
REQUIRED ONLY HUNDRED TWENTY
GRADUATE SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE
MOVED TO NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF
OUR.
I DEGREES NEEDING ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY UNITS ONLY.
THE NEXT THE ADDITIONAL FIVE
PERCENT ARE USUALLY IN THE
ENGINEERING FIELD OF THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTURE LIKE I
THINK WE MADE. A COLOSSAL
CHANGES ADMINISTRATIVELY OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS IN THAT
AREA. SO YOU DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE.
YOU NEED TO TAKE A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MINIMUM I THINK ONE
ISSUE THAT I THINK LA WAS RAISED
IN THE PAST RECENT PAST HAS
BEEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE NUMBER OF
COMMITTEE COLLEGES STUDENTS
ENTERING WITH MORE THAN SAY
SIXTY SEVENTY EIGHTY UNITS.
THAT'S
MORE UNITS BEING TAKEN BY THOSE
STUDENTS THE NECESSARY TO ONE
GET A A. OR TO TO THAN USE OVER
THE C. ISSUE SO YOU HAVE MORE
UNITS BEING CONSUMED SO TO SPEAK
BY A STUDENT. THEN WHAT WOULD
NEED TO BE.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW IF IF THE LA WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THAT THEY CAN BUT
FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF.
ART AND SCIENCE TO IT I THINK
YOU KNOW STUDENTS ARE ENTERING
THEIR COLLEGE YEARS MAYBE AS A
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENT OR
EVEN IN THE C. ISSUE. AND SOME
OF THEM DON'T QUITE KNOW YET
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO WITH THEIR
LIVES SO THEY'RE EXPLORING
DIFFERENT DEGREES RIGHT YOU
MIGHT ENTER AS A. AS A CHEM
MAJOR AND YOU MAY DECIDE CAM
ISN'T MY THING YOU MAY WANT TO
SWITCH TO A DIFFERENT GREE. SO
THOSE UNITS COULD BE ACCUMULATED
IN WAYS IN WHICH.
THIS DUDE HAD INTENDED TO GO
TOWARDS BUT THEN OPTED TO CHANGE
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO TAKE ADDITIONAL COURSES
TO TAKE A DIFFERENT AGREE
UNDERSTANDUNDERSTAND YEAH. OKAY
SO.
MY WHOLE ISSUE DRIVING THIS
DISCUSSION IS.
.
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I
THINK DESY ISSUE DOES NEED TO BE
FUNDED AT A HIGHER LEVEL.
BECAUSE I THINK THE THIRTY THREE
PERCENT THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
ISN'T REALLY.
RELEVANT TO WHAT WE NEED IN
THAT IN THIS SOCIETY WANT FOR
THE FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY THOUGH I HEAR WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S DOING I THINK SO
I SQUEEZE IN THIS YEAR'S CHOOSES
THAT WENT WHEN IF I WAS HIM I'D
USE IN OKAY. I'M GIVEN MONEY TO
THE COMMITTEE CALLED THIS YEAR'S
USE AND UNIVERSITIES AND YOU
GUYS JUST BECAUSE WE PLAY NICE
TO STREAMLINED. STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS I SEE WHERE YOU HAVE
YOUR THREE OBJECTIVES FAIR
COMPENSATION I AGREE THAT'S
WONDERFUL.
INCREASING ACCESS THAT'S NEAT.
IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES BUT I
THINK YOU ALSO AND LOOK AT A
FOURTH ELEMENT OUT BE
STREAMLINING THE COURSE
SCHEDULED TO TRANSFER LEVELS. SO
THAT THEY'RE MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE AND CHEAPER.
IN IN ACTUALLY SAY THE TIME FOR
THE STUDENTS SO.
EVEN THOUGH I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND I TOLD EVERYBODY THAT I
WOULD BE SUPPORTING THIS ISSUES
ON THE INCREASE IN FUNDING.
I AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR IN THE
SENSE THAT WE NEED TO SEE SOME
MORE EFFORT ON THEM AS THE SOLE
ISSUE TRANSFER. IN TRANSIT
TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN THE WHOLE
SYSTEM TO GET PEOPLE IN AND OUT.
SO THEY GO AND GET A JOB AND GET
OUT OF THE SCHOOLS IN. LIFE WILL
BE GOOD I WON'T GO INTO A LOT OF
DETAIL ABOUT THAT BUT ONE THING
I WANT TO POINT OUT IS IN
GENERAL WE HAVE BEEN REALLY
WORKING ON.
YOU KNOW CREATING A LOT OF THE
MINISTRY OF STREAMLINES AND ALSO
A LOT OF OTHER SUPPORTS THAT YOU
HEAR FROM THAT THE TWO
PRESIDENTS WE HAVE HERE TODAY
AND ALSO FROM ANOTHER COLLEAGUE
OF MINE. ABOUT WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN TERMS OF MOVING THE NEEDLE IN
TERMS OF GRADUATION RATES OF
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF THAT'S
HAPPENING BUT WE'LL GET INTO
THAT LIVE THE LIFE AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO BECAUSE LIKE.
IS GUYS LIKE ME HAVE BEEN A PER
FOR SIX YEARS WATCHING HIS ROLL
THROUGH AND AND A LITTLE HERE
AND I REMEMBER I AM WEIRD BRING
THEM MEMBER SENT ME TOLD ME FIVE
YEARS AGO SHALL.
WAIT TO SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN.
AND AS WE SUPPORT DSE ISSUES
WHICH I'M A GRADUATE OF CSU
CHICO.
THANKS THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT
THE NEXT ISSUE IS RELATED TO TO
THIS BECAUSE MORE SUCCESS IN TWO
HELPS WITH THE OVERALL. A
FUNDING BY I JUST WANNA KNOW TO
AS MR CHAVEZ.
STATED THAT THE WHOLE THIRTY
THREE PERCENT IN THE MASTER
PLAN.
VERSUS FORTY SOMETHING PERCENT
THAT THE FEW THINGS ONE THE
MASTER PLAN WAS NEVER AND LOST
NINETY STATE STATUTE NINETEEN
SIXTY.
AND THEN FIFTY EIGHT YEARS LATER
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT THAT
COLLEGE NEEDS ARE DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT JUST JUSTIFY YOUR OWN
COMMON SENSE WHAT IT TAKES TO
HAVE A GOOD PAYING JOB. TODAY
AND TOMORROW VERSES WHAT YOU
NEEDED NINETEEN SIXTY AND PLUS
WE HAVE HEARINGS ALL THE TIME
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE DEGREE
GAP AND SO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
EVER REACH. THAT ONE MILLION
DEGREE GAP.
IF YOU DON'T SIGNIFICANTLY HOW
RAMP UP.
ACCESS TO THE CSU SO.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT WE WANT TO
MEMORIALIZE THIS AND AUTHOR A
NEW LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL AND SAY
THAT THAT THE GOAL SHOULD BE.
FORTY PERCENT OR FIFTY PERCENT
OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS.
HOLDING BACK ON THIS ON THIS.
NUMBER FROM THE PAST THAT
REALLY WASN'T NECESSARILY EVEN
STATEWIDE SYSTEMS UP THERE.
AS FAR AS AS AS THAT SELL ALL
KNOW THAT BUT YOU OVERALL BIG
PICTURE WE WE HEAR LOUD AND
CLEAR THAT.
THE ALLOCATION THAT THE THAT
THREE PERCENT HER AS YOU SAY
ACTUALLY LASSEN THREE PERCENT
TWO POINT SEVEN OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE OF WHAT.
HAVE HAS TO BE SPENT BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
DOESN'T MEET THE OVERALL NEEDS
AS FAR AS.%
COURSE SPENDING.
ACCESS AYE I WILL NOTE THAT
THAT ONE THING THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S CERTAIN IT'S OUR
INTENTION TO DO ALL WE CAN TO.
ADEQUATELY FUND YOU SEEN SINCE
YOU WERE GONNA DO THAT.
AFTER A MEMBER REVISED THE
NUMBERS COME OUT. BUT IF THE IF
THERE IS A FINAL NUMBER THAT
COMES EITHER IN THE IN THE.
IN THE AYE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
OR YOU KNOW.
BY WHATEVER REASON THAT THAT'S
OUT THERE IS AN. OPPORTUNITY TO
ONE SEVENTY ONE I THINK THAT WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE THINK.
OUR OUR PRIORITIES ARE TOP
PRIORITIES THAT'S ACCESS AND SO.
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE REVISIT
THAT SAFE THAT.
MAYBE A SIMPLE THING WHEN YOU
PUT MAKE YOUR CHART FOR THAT BUT
THAT IS THAT THE NEXT BUCKET
THEY GETS BUILT BECAUSE. AGAIN
THAT'S
THAT'S OUR TOP PRIORITY. SO WITH
THAT.
WE WILL.
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
ANY QUESTIONS OVER HERE ALL THIS
ISSUE OPENED AND REVISITED AFTER
THE MAY REVISE AND. PULLED OUT
HERE FOR.
THE CHANCES OFFICE AS WELL AS
TO.
CSU PRESIDENTS ON THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE ACROSS
YEAH SYSTEM.
SO WELCOME BACK PRESIDENT NELSON
AND I THINK THIS IS MISTER
PRESIDENT CASTRO IS YOUR FIRST
TIME DIRECT ME CATS AYE YES HI
WELCOME TO KEEP.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE GONNA START
FIRST WITH.
JEFF GOLD WITH THE.
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
GIVE THE.
OVERVIEW OF THE SYSTEM WIDE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE GRADUATION.
INITIATIVE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING JEFF GOLD ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR STUDENT SUCCESS BUT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCES OFFICE.
IT'S A REAL PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
TODAY AND HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE
SUBJECTS THE GRADUATION THAT
SHOULD'VE.
THIS IS OUR SIGNATURE. PERFECT
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS TO EARN A
HIGH QUALITY CUTLERY TO GREET
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WHAT THE SAME TIME HAVING
INCREDIBLY INTENTIONAL FOCUS
ON CLOSING EQUITY GAPS ACROSS
THE SYSTEM?
WHICH REPRESENTS THE MOST
IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
YOU KNOW AYE AYE REFLECTING NOW
ON THE LAST PANEL AND SEVEN MEN
CHAVEZ YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR WAITING TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING. I HOPE THIS PANEL
ANSWER THAT QUESTION THERE HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
EFFORT. A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
MOMENTUM AND EARLY INDICATORS OF
SUCCESS BUT I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT THE GRAD
INITIATIVE. SO YOU HAVE A
HANDOUT THAT I PASSED OUT TO YOU
I'M GONNA GO THROUGH IT FAIRLY
BRIEFLY BECAUSE I WANT TO
PROVIDE TIME. NOT JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN OVERVIEW AT THE SYSTEM
LEVEL OF THE EFFORTS BUT TO
PROVIDE TIME FOR OUR
PRESIDENT'S.
PRESIDENT CASTRO FOR
PRESIDENT'S DAY AT PRESIDENT
NELSON FROM SACRAMENTO WHO HAVE
JOINED US I THINK IT IS A TRUE
TESTAMENT. TO HOW WOULD THIS
INITIATIVE HAS INFUSED THE
ARTERIES OF OUR CAMPUS IN THE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE HAVE. THAT
OUR PRESIDENTS HAVE TAKEN TIME
OUT OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES TO
JOIN US A THANK YOU BOTH AS
WELL.
IN OUR PACKETS I'M GONNA START
WITH THE HIGH LEVEL STORY ABOUT
THE DATA.
IT'S IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE ONE OF
THE PACKET. THERE IS A YOU'LL
NOTICE THREE LINES THAT
REPRESENT THE GRADUATION RATES
OF FRESHMEN STUDENTS OVER THE
LAST FORTY YEARS ARE STILL IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND WITHOUT GOING OVER THE
NUMBERS IN DETAIL THE RED LINE.
SHOWS THE FOR YOU SINCE YOU
GRADUATE AS FRESHMEN IN FOUR
YEARS OR LESS THE GREEN NINE
FIVE YEARS ARE LASSEN THE BLUE
LINE AT THE TOP STUFF SIX YEARS
OR LESS.
WHAT YOU WILL NOTICE FROM THIS
CHART?
AGAIN IS THE INCREDIBLE
MOVEMENT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST
THIRTY YEARS OR SO YEARS OF THE
HISTORY OF OUR GRADUATION RATES.
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT WE HAVE SOME
PRETTY INCREMENTAL AND SMALL
IMPROVEMENTS IN TERMS OF.
IMPROVEMENTS IN GRADUATION
RATES IF YOU KINDA SQUINT YOUR
EYES AND LOOK AT THAT TAIL END
OF THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSED INTENTIONALLY ON
GRADUATION RATES FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS. YOU'LL SEE A FAIRLY
PRECIPITOUS MOVEMENT AND ALL
THREE LINES NORTHWARDS
SO THIS REPRESENTS OUR CONCERTED
EFFORTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
IS A SYSTEM. UP TO PUT STUDENT
SUCCESS FIRST AND TO FOCUS ON IT
INTENTIONALLY AND ALL CAMPUSES
A QUICK REMINDER FROM THE PANEL
BEFORE IS THAT. THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS CAMPEONATOS FAMILIES
EVERY ONE PERCENTAGE POINT HERE
MAY SEEM LIKE A SMALL NUMBER
MOVING FROM FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT
TO FIFTY NINE PERCENT. BUT THAT
REPRESENTS IMPROVEMENT FOR
HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THE STATE OF
SOUTH.
SAY THEY GET EVERYONE PERCENT
HAS HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS BECAUSE
WE HAVE AS WE MENTIONED BEFORE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND AFTER. HE'S
EVERYONE PERCENTAGE POINT
INCREASES HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF STUDENTS THAT THAT ATTAINED
AGREE THAT MAYBE THAT MAY NOT
HAVE.
HAVE HAD WE NOT OTHERWISE. HAVE
THESE EFFORTS A PLACE.
SO THIS EFFORT IS REALLY A
STRATEGIC EFFORT THAT IS BASED
ON THE PHILOSOPHY.
WE PUT A STAKE IN THE GROUND AND
MEASURE PROGRESS
SLIDE TWO SHOWS US HOW WE WENT
ABOUT MEASURING THAT AND HOW WE
SET UP THE THE THE.
AMBITIOUS GOALS THAT WE HAVE.
THE SLIDE SHOWS UP HERE GROUP
FOR CINEMA STATE WHAT WE DID TWO
YEARS AGO WE SET UP THESE
BENCHMARK AMBITIOUS GOALS. IS
THAT WE FOUND PEER DATA FOR EACH
ONE OF OUR TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
AND SET A PLOT SO THAT EACH
CAMPUS WOULD HAVE GRADUATION
RATES IN THE TOP QUARTILE THE
TOP TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THEIR NATIONAL PEERS ABOVE AND
BEYOND THAT WE SENATE GROWTH
THAT TRAJECTORY FOR THEM TO
INCREASE BEYOND THAT. SO WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR THOSE CAMPUSES TO BE
AS GOOD AS THEIR PEERS ARE
TODAY.
THE BILL THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WAS TO GET INTO TO BE
THE BASS IN THEY TO INCREASE
THAT ALL THE WAY THROUGHOUT. SO
THERE'S A WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN
SEE FOR EACH CAMPUS AYE WE SET
THIS OUT.
AND AND WHERE IT'S TAKING US.
RETURN TO SIDE THREE IT BRINGS
US TO THE AGGREGATE OF THOSE
TWENTY THREE CAMPUS SCHOOLS
WHICH ARE INCREDIBLY AMBITIOUS.
WHAT FROM THE LEFT YOU CAN SEE
THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
UNDERNEATH THE TASSEL IS A
TWENTY THREE PERCENT WERE WE SET
NOW? AND WHERE WE'RE HEADED IS
FORTY PERCENT BY YEAR BY YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. ALTHOUGH TH
WAY THROUGHOUT WE HAVE A FOCUS
ON ALL STUDENTS. YOU CAN READ
THE NUMBERS I WANT YOUR YOUR
TAKE AWAY FROM THE SLIGHT TO BE
THAT IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
NUMBERS.
BEHIND THE TWENTY THESE
PERCENTAGES OF ONE I REITERATE
THAT THIS IS HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS OF IMPROVEMENT.
AND THAT EACH ONE OF THE
STUDENTS IS A STUDENT'S LIFE.
AND.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED. GIVING ON NOTICE ON
THE BOTTOM IS THAT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP GOAL OF HAVING
ZERO EQUITY GAPS THROUGHOUT
THEIR SYSTEM IS WHAT DRIVES MOST
OF US INDEED. IF YOU WALK THE
HALLS OF OUR CAMPUSES AND YOU
HAPPEN TO RUN INTO FACULTY STAFF
ADMINISTRATORS THEY WILL OFTEN
TELL YOU THAT THAT IS A PRIMARY
DRIVER OF WHY THEY GET UP IN THE
MORNING. Y. THAT SO THEY ARE SO
PROUD TO BE PART OF THE CSU AS
THIS INHERENT DRIVE TO DO BETTER
FOR MOST UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
FIVE FOUR SHOWS YOU HOW WE WENT
ABOUT ORGANIZING THIS WORK.
AFTER WE SET THESE AMBITIOUS
GOALS WITH A THAT WITH THAT.
CROSSBREED BOTH OF CAMPUS
CONSTITUENTS WITHIN ONE ABOUT
ASSN THE CAMPUSES WHAT THEIR
PLANS WERE TO HIT THE SCHOOLS.
AND WHEN WE LOOK THROUGH THE
PLANS AND ANALYZE THEM THERE
WERE REALLY SIX MAJOR FOCAL
AREAS THAT CAME ABOUT.
STARTING FROM THE RIGHT
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS WHICH IS
REMOVING IMPEDIMENTS TO STUDENTS
PROGRESS TOWARDS A DEGREE.
LEVERAGING DATA TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS ABOUT STUDENT SUCCESS.
BEING CREATIVE ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT WE
PROVIDE TO OUR STUDENTS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS HAVE THE PATH TO THE
DEGREE THAT THEY NEED.
OF STUDENT ENGAGEMENT WELL BEING
AS THE NEXT ONE WHICH REALLY
CREATES THAT SENSE OF BELONGING
THIS NOT JUST IN THE CLASSROOM.
BUT WITH CO CURRICULAR THAT
CONNECTING OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM.
THE ROLE THAT MANAGEMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL
TELL US IS ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL COMPONENTS WHICH IS
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS HAVE THE
COURSES THEY NEED. WHEN THEY
NEED THEM AND LASTLY I JUST
SPEND A MINUTE ON ACADEMIC
PREPARATION BECAUSE IT'S AN AREA
WHERE I'M INCREDIBLY PROUD.
BEGINNING THIS FALL FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE COMPLETELY TRANSFORMED
THE WAY THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
DEVELOPMENTAL SUPPORT EDUCATION.
SO ASSEMBLYMAN CHAVEZ MENTIONED
LAST PANEL IS WAITING FOR THE
TIME IS WE NEED TO SEE THE
PROGRESS.
THIS IS A MONUMENTAL THIS IS
TRANSFORMATIVE THAT'S IS
CHANGING THE APPROACH THAT WE
HAVE TO PROVIDING THE SUPPORT
THAT STUDENTS NEED. AND INSTEAD
OF THEM COMING TO US AS STUDENTS
HAVE FOR YEARS AND YEARS
RECEIVING THE MESSAGE FORTY
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVING THE MESSAGE THAT
THEY'RE NOT QUITE READY TO BE AT
THE UNIVERSITY.
THAT THEY NEED TO TAKE COURSES
THAT WALKOUT FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME IN OUR HISTORY BEGINNING
THIS FALL WE ARE TELLING HIM
THAT NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE WE
ARE READY FOR YOU. AND THAT IS A
HUGE TRANSFORMATION TO PROVIDE
THE SUPPORT THAT STUDENTS NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT IN THAT FIRST
YEAR TO MAKE SURE THEY GOT TO
GET OFF TO A GREAT START.
BUT LAST TWO SLIDES I WANT TO
SHOW YOU THE IMPACT OF THIS I
THINK CAN'T BE UNDERSTATED.
AGAIN DEAR DO YOU DO TO OUR
SHARED NUMBER.
WE WILL WHEN WE HIT THESE
AMBITIOUS GOALS BECOME THE
LEADING THE NATIONAL FLAGSHIP
FOR PUBLIC FOR YOUR
COMPREHENSIVES IN THE YEAH
AROUND THE NATION.
SO WE SET GOALS TO BE AT THE TOP
OF OUR PEERS WHEN WE HIT THOSE
GOALS WHEN HE.
BECAUSE THE AMBITIOUS TARGETS
THAT I REVIEWED WE WILL BE THE
LEADER IT SERVES A FOR YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE UNIVERSITIES AND
NOT JUST BE KNOWN FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT WE LIVE IN THE
DOOR. BUT THE STUDENTS THAT WE
GRADUATE.
LASTLY I JUST WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THREE CLOSING THOUGHTS
WHICH IS THE LAST BY.
IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO TELL
FROM THE THE CONVERSATION
ALREADY THE STAKES ARE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
I I BELIEVE THAT.
YOU HAD TESTIMONY FROM THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE PAST TO TALK
ABOUT THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
WORK WE'RE DOING AND THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THAT GAP
THAT DEGREE GAP THAT SINCE
THE PAID IT TO BE EXIST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BETWEEN
THOSE WHO HAVE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES OF THOSE THAT DON'T AND
THE WORK FORCE TRENDS THAT
REQUIRE THOSE DEGREES.
SO THERE'S A PREDICTION FOR THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE THAT WE
WILL BE ABOUT ONE POINT ONE
MILLION POPULAR DEGREE SHORT BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND THE CSU IS
BEING THE BIGGEST GAME IN THE
STATE.
WILL CONTRIBUTE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THOSE
ADDITIONAL DEGREES ADDITIONAL
DEGREES BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY. SO WE ARE ON TRACK TO DO
THAT.
SECONDLY IN AGAIN AS EVIDENCED
BY PRESIDENTS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
CAMPUS LEADERSHIP IS ESSENTIAL
AND I WANT TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND NOT JUST. YOU KNOW.
BRING OUT THAT PLATITUDE.
IT IS REALLY INCREDIBLE WHEN YOU
WALK THROUGH OUR CAMPUSES AND
YOU SEE THE INTENTIONALITY IN
THE FOCUS THAT WE HAVE AS A
SYSTEM. NOT JUST ON THESE TWO
CAMPUSES BUT ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
ALL GROWING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION FOR THIS INITIATIVE
IT'S TRULY IMPRESSIVE AND THIS
IS THE TIME THAT WE NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE. WHICH
BRINGS ME TO THE VERY LAST.
BULLET.
FOR THE DAY FOR ME WHICH IS
THAT SUSTAIN STATE FIVE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR SUCCESS.
I AM I THINK YOU HEARD IN THE
LAST PANEL LOVES A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT BUT LET ME JUST
REITERATE THAT STUDENT SUCCESS
IS NOT FREE.
WHAT I TALKED ABOUT HOW WE USE
DATA TO IDENTIFY THE PEER
COMPARISON GROUPS FOR OUR TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES? WE ALSO LOOKED
UNDER THE HOOD A LITTLE BIT TO
SEE HOW MUCH THOSE PIERCED BAND
ON STUDENT SUCCESS HOW MUCH THEY
SPEND ON HIRING FACULTY. TENURE
TRACK FACULTY HOW MUCH THEY
SPEND ON GETTING THE NEEDED
ADVISORS AND SUPPORT STRUCTURE.
AND ON AVERAGE THEY SPEND OVER
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
WHEN YOU MULTIPLY THAT BY OUR
STUDENT POPULATION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
ANNUAL INVESTMENTS OF AN
ADDITIONAL HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET THE RESULTS THAT
WE WANT TO GET.
IT'S A WITHOUT CONTEXT I LEAVE
YOU THAT.
WHICH IS THE IDEA THAT THIS
INVESTMENT IN THAT IN THAT CSU
IS AN INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AT
ONE OF THE MOST OF THAT'S NOT
IMPORTANT THAT STUDENTS THAT
WILL MAKE.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT NELSON.
HOME COURT ADVANTAGE. THEY.
STINGERS UP.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I'M PLEASED TO REPORT
BACK TO YOU ON THE PROGRESS
BEING MADE SACRAMENTO STATE TO
IMPROVE OUR TIME TO DEGREE. AND
TO REDUCE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AS YOU'VE HEARD ME TESTIFY
BEFORE SACRAMENTO STATE IN THE
MIST OF A CULTURE CHANGE THAT IS
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
TO TAKE A FULL COURSE LOAD OF
FIFTEEN CREDITS.
FIFTEEN PLUS FIFTEEN EQUALS
THIRTY TIMES FOUR EQUALS ONE
TWENTY EQUALS A DEGREE.
TO KEEP SEX EIGHT END OF THE
BARGAIN WITH THE STUDENTS WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THE CLASSES
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM AND THAT
WE SUPPORT THEM ACADEMICALLY AND
FINANCIALLY.
THE CULTURE CHANGE ISRAEL AND
HAS BEEN EMBRACED BY OUR
STUDENTS.
BECAUSE OF OUR FINISH IN FOUR
AND OUR THROUGH INTO. CAMPAIGNS
SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR INCOMING
GRADUATES
STUDENTS NOW EXPECT TO GRADUATE
IN FOUR YEARS.
AND EIGHTY THREE PERCENT OF THE
INCOMING.
FALL TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FRESHMAN PLEDGE TO TAKE A FULL
COURSE LOAD WHICH IS UPSET FROM
SIXTY TWO PERCENT THE YEAR
BEFORE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ACADEMIC HERE WE HAVE
ADDED SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX ADDITIONAL COURSES.
THAT AVERAGE UNIT LOAD FOR THE
FRESHMAN'S FIRST SEMESTER IS NOW
FOURTEEN POINT SIX.
UNITS
UP FROM A TRADITIONAL AVERAGE OF
ONE OF ELEVEN TO TWELVE UNITS.
WE ARE OFFERING SUMMER INCENTIVE
GRANTS%
AND WE'VE HIRED A ACADEMIC
ADVISORS AND MADE DEGREE PLANS
ACCESSIBLE ONLINE WITH SMART
PLANNER.
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE HAVE BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING OVER ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
ADDITIONAL FACULTY MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO TELL YOU THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE COME
OUT THAT HAVE YOU COSTS ARE
PAYING OFF.
IN ONE YEAR LOAN FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE IMPROVED OVER
THREE PER.
SANTEE POINTS FOR ME EIGHT POINT
EIGHT TO TWELVE POINT ZERO A
THIRTY SIX PERCENT INCREASE.
FIFTY ONE PERCENT OF OUR
FRESHMEN STUDENTS ARE NOW TAKING
AND PASSING FIFTEEN UNITS IN
THEIR FIRST SEMESTER.
FOR ME PERSONALLY IT HAS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY THAT THESE.
GAINES IMPROVE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE OF ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING STUDENTS FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
I'M CLOUT IT IN CREDIBLY PROUD
TO REPORT. THAT WE HAVE SEEN AT
LEAST TEN PERCENTAGE POINT.
INCREASED IN ALL ETHNIC AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC.
GROUPS COMPLETING FIFTEEN OR
MORE UNITS IN THEIR.
FIRST SEMESTER.
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS HAVE A
FIFTEEN POINT ONE PERCENTAGE
POINT INCREASE IN COMPLETING
FIFTEEN OR MORE UNITS LATINO
STUDENTS HAD A TWELVE POINT
THREE PERCENTAGE POINT INCREASE.
LOW INCOME PAL STUDENTS HAD A
TEN POINT SEVEN PERCENT.
IN POINT INCREASE IN COMPLETING
FIFTEEN.
YOU NOT SIR MORE THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY HUGE.
AND DAY BY DAY THAT SEX STATE
WE'RE SEEING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
BETWEEN ANGLO AND HISPANIC
STUDENTS NEARER TO THE POINT
WHERE IT IS DISAPPEARING.
I KNOW THAT THIS MAY BE HARD TO
BELIEVE.
BUT THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION
RATE.
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BETWEEN HISPANIC
AND ANGLO STUDENTS HAS BEEN
ELIMINATED.
THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
HISPANIC STUDENTS
IS NOW ONE HALF PERCENT. HIGHER.
THEN CAUCASIAN STUDENTS
A SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE.
BOB PERCENTAGE POINT GAP.
HAS BEENA SEVEN PERCENT.
PERCENTAGE POINT GAP HAS BEEN
CLOSED AND THE ELIMINATED.
AS OUR EFFORTS ARE SUSTAIN FOR
THE FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS WHO WERE ARRIVED ON
CAMPUS IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. I EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO REPORT EVEN LARGER GAINS
NEXT YEAR.
HOWEVER WE MUST REMEMBER THAT
NONE OF THESE ACTIONS ARE COST
FREE. LABOR CARD ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS FROM THE STATE AND
FROM THE CSU SYSTEM.
THIS SUMMER WE ARE INVESTING.
TO THE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS INCENTIVE
GRANTS TO INCREASE THE USE OF
THE SUMMER SESSION WHERE FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE YEAR ROUND TELL.
THE HUNDRED NEW HUNDRED SIXTY
NEW FACULTY WHO ARE PROVIDING
THE COURSES THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR THE STUDENTS TO TAKE A FULL
FIFTEEN UNIT COURSE LOAD. MUST
BE PAID AND CANNOT BE PAID BY
ONE TIME MONEY.
THE SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX COURSE SECTIONS THAT WE'VE
ADDED IN THE LAST TWO YEARS MUST
BE TAUGHT.
AGAIN.
AND THEY MUST BE SCHEDULED.
THOSE COURSE SECTIONS COST THE
UNIVERSITY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT CURRENTLY I
DO NOT HAVE IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET.
AS I SAID EARLIER BECAUSE OF OUR
FINISH IN FOUR CAMPAIGN OVER
SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS.
INCOMING STUDENTS EXPECT TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS WE CANNOT
LET THEM DOWN AND WE MUST NOT
LET THEM DOWN.
THE TRUTH IS THAT GIVEN THE
PROPOSED STATE ALLOCATIONS NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET IS LOOKING TO BE
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULTY.
DIFFICULT I HAVE ASKED EACH OF
MY DEPARTMENTS TO PLAN ON A
THREE PERCENT.
TO A FOUR POINT FIVE PERCENT
REDUCTION.
IF WE'RE NOT FULLY FUNDED EACH
OF THE ACADEMIC DEPARTMENTS WILL
HAVE TO SEE THESE CUTS.
AND THESE CUTS WILL HURT OUR
STUDENTS AND WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUSTAIN THE SUCCESS THAT I'VE
JUST OUTLINED FOR YOU.
AT RISK ARE ALL THE GAINS THAT
WE HAVE MADE TO THIS DAY.
WE AT SAC STATE AND IN THE CSU
SYSTEM HAVE DELIVERED ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S MANDATE TO IMPROVE
TIME TO DEGREE.
GIVEN THAT CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
FINDS ITSELF IN A SURPLUS THIS
YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FULLY FUND THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
REQUEST.
SO THAT WE DO NOT LET OUR
STUDENTS DOWN AND SO THAT WE
DON'T IRREPARABLY HARM
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
YES WE'LL GET INTO THAT AFTER I
HEAR FROM MR CASTRO WITHOUT SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MCCARTY AND MEMBERS THE
BULLDOGS IN THE HORNETS GET
ALONG REALLY WELL AND I'M HAPPY
TO TO JOIN PRESIDENT NELSON HERE
IN THE CAPITAL TODAY. AND MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES.
TO SHARE HOW THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN OUR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY STRENGTHENED
FRESNO STATE'S ABILITY TO SERVE
AND ARE VERY TALENTED AND IS
DIVERSE STUDENTS.
FRESNO STATE WITH ITS TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS IS THE
LARGEST UNIVERSITY IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AN AREA OF THE STATE THAT YOU
KNOW HAS EXTRAORDINARY
POTENTIAL.
NINETY PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
COME FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
OVER SEVENTY PERCENT OF THEM ARE
FIRST GENERATION TO COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND OVER SIXTY PERCENT
ARE PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS.
I AM BRACE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THE STUDENTS BECAUSE I AM
THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF FRESNO
STATE FROM THE REGION AND I
SHARE MUCH IN COMMON. WITH.
ARE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
OVER EIGHTY PERCENT OF OUR
GRADUATES
REMAIN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
BECOME LEADERS IN A WIDE ARRAY
OF PROFESSIONS AN ASIAN AMERICAN
NATIVE
AMERICAN.
I WONDER SERVING INSTITUTION.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS THE STAKES
ARE HIGH FOR CALIFORNIA. AND FOR
THE ENTIRE CENTRAL VALLEY.
LIKE THE OTHER TWENTY TWO CSU
CAMPUSES FRESNO STATE HAS SET
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS.
FOR EXAMPLE OUR SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES TARGET IS
SEVENTY PERCENT AND WE'RE
CLOSING IN ON SIXTY PERCENT.
OUR TWO YEAR AND FOUR YEAR
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATES HAVE
ALSO INCREASED WITH THE TWO YEAR
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATE. GOING
FROM TWENTY TWO PERCENT TO
ALMOST TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS ALONE.
THE STUDENT SUCCESS GOALS ARE
CENTRAL A A CENTRAL COMPONENT OF
OUR CAMPUS STRATEGIC PLAN AND
CONSISTENT WITH OUR MISSION AT
FRESNO STATE WHICH IS TO BOLDLY
EDUCATE AND EMPOWER. OUR
STUDENTS FOR SUCCESS.
OUR CAMPUS AND THE REGION ARE
ALIGNED IN OUR VISION FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS.
BUT THIS VISION AS PRESIDENT
NELSON SAID.
I CAN ONLY BE FULLY REALIZED
WITH THE STATE RESOURCES THAT
ARE PROVIDED NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE FOR GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
WE HAVE YEARS GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FUNDING THIS YEAR.
A TOTAL OF ABOUT FOUR POINT
THREE FIVE MILLION AND PERMANENT
FUNDS AND ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX THOUSAND AND ONE TIME
FUNDS.
TO HIRE NEW TENURE TRACK
FACULTY.
ACADEMIC ADVISORS AND STUDENT
SERVICES STAFF.
THE ADDITIONAL FACULTY HAVE
ENABLED US TO ASSURE ALL NEW
STUDENTS SAY FIFTEEN UNIT COURSE
LOAD THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
BOTH A AND AND THE OTHER
PRESIDENTS. ARE FOCUSED ON AND
THAT KEEPS THEM ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS IF THEY
ARE FRESHMEN.
A AND TO YEARS IF THERE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS
AND I KNOW THAT INCREASING
COURSE LOAD IS A PRIORITY FOR
FOR YOU AND FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
AND SUSTAINED FUNDING IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE TO GAIN ACCESS TO A
FULL COURSE LOAD AND GRADUATE IN
A TIMELY WAY.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE ALLOCATED
FUNDS FOR NEW INITIATIVES SUCH
AS OUR BULLDOG RETENTION GRANTS
AND THESE GRANTS ARE AWARDED TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE ON TRACK TO
ENROLL.
IN GRADUATE BUT HAVE A
FINANCIAL SHORT.
I SHORTFALL OF LESS THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND ARE SUBJECT TO BEING
CANCELED AND DROP FROM ALL
CLASSES.
AND IN THE PAST THAT MAY HAVE
HAPPENED.
BUT NOW WE HAVE AWARDED NINETY
TWO GRANTS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. OF FIFTEEN OF THOSE
STUDENTS GRADUATED IN SEVENTY
SEVEN OF THOSE STUDENTS WERE
RETAINED SO INSTEAD OF LOSING
OUR STUDENTS.
THEY STAYED AND THEY'RE
GRADUATING AND FALL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE AWARDED TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE GRANTS
RANGING FROM FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
DOLLARS. TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF OUR GI
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FUNDS HAVE
ALSO BEEN USED TO SCALE UP
SUCCESSFUL INITIATIVES.
INCLUDING CO REQUISITE COURSES
AND SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION.
AND IN THIS ACADEMIC YEAR ALONE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE THAT TWENTY SIX
NEW CO REQUISITE COURSES IN
THIRTY TWO NEW SECTIONS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION.
AND THAT'S APPROVING HIGH IMPACT
PRACTICE THAT PLAYS A CRITICAL
ROLE IN RAISING COURSE GRADES IN
ELIMINATING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR PREVIOUSLY HIGH
FAILURE RATE COURSES REPEAT
COURSES AND GATEWAY BOTTLENECK
COURSES.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR STUDY
OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. IS THAT
STUDENTS WHO HAVE SIXTEEN OR
MORE VISITS WITH ANTS
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION ERNIE
MEAN FINANCIAL COURSE GRADE. OF
ONE LETTER HIGHER THAN THOSE WHO
ARE NOT IN THIS PROGRAM AND THE
OVERALL COURSE.
PASS RATES AVERAGE ABOUT NINETY
FOUR PERCENT.
AND WE LOOKED AT THE COHORT OF
STUDENTS
S.. USING THIS WHO STARTED AS
FRESHMEN AND TWENTY ELEVEN
TWELVE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION. THEIR
GRADUATION RATES FOR NEARLY
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
IN COMPARISON TO STUDENTS WHO
WERE NOT IN SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION.
AND AS YOU KNOW WELL DIGITAL
LEDGER LITERACY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. OUR STUDENTS MUST BE
ADEPT IN THIS DIGITAL AGE AND
ASSEMBLYMAN CHAVEZ MENTIONED
THIS EARLIER MANY ARE ALREADY
SAVVY WITH TECHNOLOGY. BUT ALL
OF THEM NEED TO LEARN HOW TO
SOURCE TRUSTED CONTENT TO FACT
FIND ANALYZE AND LEARN. AND FOR
THIS REASON WE'VE INVESTED SOME
OF OUR GI TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FUNDS INTO THIS AREA. OUR
PROGRAM DISCOVER <c.green> WHICH
IS</c>
OUR CAMPUSES DIGITAL INITIATIVE
HAS EXPANDED FACULTY CURRICULUM
LEVERAGING OPEN SOURCE DIGITAL
CONTENT IN A TECHNOLOGY INFUSED
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. AND THE
RESULTS OF THAT PROGRAM HAVE
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATED.
THAT PARTICIPATING STUDENTS
HAVE HIRE PURCHASE A RETENTION
RATES HIGHER END OF TERM GPAS
AND ARE ON TRACK TO GRADUATE ON
TIME. AND THEN VERY IMPORTANTLY
FOR OUR STUDENTS WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO SAVE AN AVERAGE OF SEVENTY
PERCENT ON TEXTBOOK COSTS.
FRESNO STATE SERVES A RAPIDLY
GROWING REGION THAT NEEDS MORE
RESIDENTS WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN JEFF MENTIONED THE PP
I SEE REPORT.
EARLIER.
WHEN I LOOK AT THAT REPORT AND
I SAW THAT THEY FOUND IF YOU
WERE TO DISTRIBUTE BACHELOR'S
DEGREES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO POPULATION.
THE VALLEY WOULD PRODUCE TWICE
AS MANY. AS WE ARE TODAY. AND SO
THAT IS THE GAP THAT I SEE FOR
OUR REGION. AND UNFORTUNATELY
WHILE THIS IS HAPPENING. DUE TO
FUNDING LIMITATIONS FRESNO STATE
IS NOW HAVING TO DENY ADMISSION
TO FIVE THOUSAND ACADEMICALLY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND THIS PAST
FALL FALL SEVENTEEN. AND
PROBABLY MORE FOR FALL EIGHTEEN.
SO I AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARTY THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO SUPPORT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH SO THAT WE CAN ENROLL AND
HELP TO GRADUATE.
STUDENTS COMING FROM ARCADE
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS AS WELL
AS OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND WITH OUR MANY EDUCATION
BUSINESS PARTNERS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROMISE.
ASSEMBLYMAN AROUND WILL HIS HIS
HELPED US WITH THAT PROGRAM. AND
THE PROMISES A COMMUNITY WIDE
EFFORT TO PROMOTE COLLEGES A
VIABLE OPTION
FOR YOUTH IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE PROMISE WILL ENSURE THAT IF
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS
PLEDGED TO DO WHAT IT TAKES AND
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL.
TO PREPARE COLLEGE WILL BE THERE
FOR THEM IN THE FUTURE
GUARANTEED AND WERE VERY PLEASED
TO JOIN OUR AREA K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS. AND
DEVELOPING COMMON STANDARDS TO
HELP OUR FUTURE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES MOST OF THE
STUDENTS AGAIN ARE FIRST
GENERATION TO COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND AND TO COMPLETE WHAT
IS REQUIRED TO BE READY. FOR
COLLEGE.
I WANT TO END MY REMARKS WITH A
VERY BRIEF STORY AND I KNOW YOU
HEAR A LOT OF STORIES BUT I I
THINK THIS ONE WILL MAKE AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
SHORTLY AFTER I WAS APPOINTED AS
PRESIDENT OF FRESNO STATE AUGUST
OF TWENTY THIRTEEN. A GRADUATE
STUDENT CAME INTO MY OFFICE
AND SHE BROUGHT HER MASTER'S
PROJECT.
AND THAT MASTER'S PROJECT
DOCUMENTED FOR THE FIRST TIME.
STUDENT FOOD SICK INSECURITY ON
OUR CAMPUS.
I WAS DEEPLY SADDENED TO LEARN
THAT AT LEAST A THIRD OF THE
STUDENTS AND THAT STUDY AT THAT
TIME.
SAID THAT THEY WERE FOOD
INSECURE. AND SOME WERE ACTUALLY
DUMPSTER DIVING NEAR MY OFFICE
TO GET FOOD.
MY WIFE MARY AND I IMMEDIATELY
MOBILIZED OUR CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THIS CHALLENGING TO PUT A
COMPREHENSIVE INITIATIVE IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS IT.
YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN TODAY'S
WASHINGTON POST THE DOCUMENTS
THIS ISSUE NATIONALLY.
BUT I AM PLEASED TO SHARE THAT
ARE STUDENT CUPBOARD WHICH WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
HAS SERVED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS.
THE COVER NAME COMES FROM.
OUR EXPERIENCE AS KIDS WHEN MY
GRANDMOTHER WOULD OPEN A
CUPBOARD AND GIVE THE FOOD THAT
SHE HAD SO THAT I COULD. GET
THROUGH COLLEGE AND THE SAME
WITH MY WIFE AND HER
GRANDMOTHER.
OUR MOST RECENT DATA HAS SHOWN
THAT STUDENTS WHO ABUSE THE
CUPBOARD ARE DOING MUCH BETTER
ACADEMICALLY. THAN THEY WERE
BEFORE THEY WERE USING THE
CUPBOARD.
THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THE
TREMENDOUS GOOD THAT COMES WHEN
OUR STATE. OUR CSU AND OUR
COMMUNITY COME TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS A SERIOUS NEED.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE TIME IS
NOW FOR US THE STATE AND THE
CSU.
TO CONTINUE ON THIS IS VERY
POSITIVE PATH.
WITH GI TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
YES IT WILL REQUIRE THE
INVESTMENT OF ADDITIONAL
PROMINENT STATE RESOURCES.
THE I PROMISE AND I KNOW
PRESIDENT NELSON PROMISES WE
WILL STEWARD CAREFULLY. ON YOUR
BEHALF.
THIS IS ONE OF THE VERY BEST
INVESTMENTS THAT WE CAN MAKE AS
A STATE.
IT WILL HELP TO UNLEASH THE
TALENT THAT EXISTS IN EVERY
HOUSEHOLD IN THE VALLEY AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IF ON THE OTHER HAND FUNDING IS
NOT PROVIDED TO SUSTAIN OR GI
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EFFORTS.
OUR MOMENTUM WILL BE SLOWED
DRAMATICALLY.
IT WILL TAKE STUDENTS LONGER TO
GRADUATE BECAUSE WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO EMPLOY. ENOUGH TACKLE TO
TO SUSTAIN OUR FIFTEEN UNIT
GUARANTEE. AND ARE POSITIVE
GRADUATION RATE TRAJECTORY WILL
FLATTEN OUT BECAUSE WE WILL NEED
TO REDUCE AND OR ELIMINATE. SOME
SUPPORT PROGRAMS FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
THE OVERALL QUALITY OF THE CSU
EDUCATION WILL BE DIMINISHED IN
THIS SCENARIO AND OUR GRADUATES
WILL BE LESS PREPARED TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESS THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE RAPIDLY
CHANGING WORKFORCE.
AND IF NO ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO THE CSU
FRESNO STATE WILL HAVE TO LOSE
OUR MISSIONS FOR NEW. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFERS IN THE SPRING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. WHICH WILL
DECREASE ACCESS FOR UP TO A
THOUSAND VALLEY STUDENTS.
AS I MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING
OF MY REMARKS A CENTRAL VALLEY
HAS EXTRAORDINARY UNREALIZED
ECONOMIC POTENTIAL. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT AND OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO UNLEASH THAT
POTENTIAL. AND YOUR SUPPORT OF
GI TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ONE ABLE
FRESNO STATE AND THE OTHER
TWENTY TWO CAMPUSES.
TO ME ARE BOLD STUDENT SUCCESS
GOALS
CALIFORNIA WILL BENEFIT FOR
DECADES TO COME FROM THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT.
THAT WE PROVIDE TODAY FOR OUR
TALENTED STUDENTS WHO ARE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF LEADERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
LOOKING AT.
PAGE ONE OF THE HANDUT THAT.
CSU PROVIDED ON GRADUATION RATES
IT. WASN'T VERY LONG AGO THAT.
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATES WERE
BELOW TEN PERCENT.
SYSTEM WIDE AND SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES WERE BELOW
FORTY PERCENT
SYSTEM WIDE.
SO IT'S REALLY ENCOURAGING
SEE THOSE GRADUATION RATES
A STEADILY INCREASING AND AND
KEEP INCREASING.
THE COURAGE IT'S ENCOURAGING AS
WELL.
THAT
I CSU IS SET SUCH SUCH AMBITIOUS
GOALS.
OVER THE NEXT SEVEN YEARS.
SEEKING TO NEARLY DOUBLE THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO.
I. THINK CURRY JANE TO SEE I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE.
AS THE AGENDA NOTES ON THE
TABLE ON PAGE EIGHT ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS.
CONTINUE TO PERSIST.
I WHICH IS TROUBLING AND
SOMETHING THAT.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY HAS
PLEDGED TO REALLY ADDRESS AND
AND ELIMINATE. OVER THE NEXT
SEVEN YEARS.
IN OUR ANALYSIS
WE IDENTIFY SEVERAL.
POTENTIAL AREAS FOR CS YOU TO
ADVANCE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
GOALS.
AND.
TO DO SO IN AN EFFICIENT MANNER.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO. TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OF THOSE OF.
POINTS THAT WE MAKE.
AND IN PARTICULAR WE KNOW THAT.
CSU STUDENTS CONTINUE TO ACCRUE.
AND MANY MORE UNITS THAN THEY
NEED TO GRADUATE.
AND STUDENTS WHO WOULD ACCRUE
MORE UNITS THAN THEIR DEGREE
REQUIRES GENERALLY TAKE LONGER
TO GRADUATE IT ALSO COSTS.
THEMSELVES IN THE STATE MORE
MONEY IN IT ANNA CROWDS OUT
OTHER STUDENTS.
SO THE AGENDA ON THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE TWELVE.
MENTIONS.
WHAT COULD BE THE KIND OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE POTENTIAL?
ARE FOR.
BEING MORE EFFICIENT WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES BY REDUCING
ACCESS UNITS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAVEZ YOU MENTION THAT AND IN
ISSUE ONE. I CSU RECENTLY
CALCULATED THAT REDUCING JUST
ONE ACCESS UNIT PERSEUS YOU
GRADUATE. WOULD BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF FREEING UP MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
COURSE SECTIONS AND REDUCING.
ACCESS UNIT TAKING BY HALF WHICH
IS A BODY ABOUT TEN. UNITS
PER THAT CSU GRADUATE WOULD BE
THE EQUIVALENT OF FREEING UP
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND COURSE
SECTIONS.
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
MONEY.
THE AGENDA REFERENCE IS A RECENT
REPORT BY CAL STATE UNIVERSITY'S
STUDENT SUCCESS NETWORK REPORT
IS TITLED GET ME FROM POINT A TO
POINT B. WHICH JUST. CAME OUT
LAST MONTH
BASED ON SURVEYS AND INTERVIEWS
WITH STUDENTS THE REPORT FINDS
THAT WHEN STUDENTS AREN'T ABLE
TO GET INTO A COURSE THEY NEED.
I THINK PRESIDENT CASTRO
REFERRED TO IS GATEWAY
BOTTLENECK COURSE.
MANY END UP SIGNING UP FOR
COURSES THEY DON'T NEED.
SO THAT THEY CAN MAINTAIN A FULL
TIME COURSE LOAD
AND AND THAT'S AN INDICATION R.
TO US THAT CSU HAS AND CONTINUES
TO HAVE A.
A MISMATCH OF SORTS BETWEEN THE
COURSES THAT CAMPUSES OFFER. AND
THE COURSES THAT STUDENTS
ACTUALLY NEED A THEIR DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS.
NOW SEE US YES YOU ARE HAS.
UNDERTAKEN EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THIS OUR. PRESIDENT NELSON
MENTIONED SMART PLANNER.
AND SMART PLANNERS THE TOOL TO
THAT PROVIDES AYE DATA TWO
CAMPUSES ON WHAT STUDENTS NEED.
.
AMONG OTHER ATTRIBUTES AND THAT
THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HELP
SO THAT'S THAT'S ENCOURAGING AS
WELL THAT A SAX STATE AND
OTHERS.
OF ARE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
ISSUE.
OF THE AGENDA ALSO NOTES OF THIS
ON PAGE THIRTEEN. THAT OUR
STUDENTS
ARM ARE REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR
ADVISING THAT IS TAILORED TO
THEIR MAJOR.
THEY WANT MORE HELP.
MAPPING OUT.
TERM BY TERM THE COURSES THAT
THEY THEIR REQUIREMENTS THEY
NEED TO MEET IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE. GOING BEYOND JUST A
SEMESTER AT A TIME LOOKING OUT.
FOR A FOUR YEAR PLAN WHAT WILL
IT TAKE TO ACTUALLY GRADUATE AND
WHAT DO THEY NEED TO TAKE.
AND CAMPUSES ARE USING.
.
TOOLS A SMART PLANNER OTHER E.
ADVISING TOOLS ARE TO HELP IN
THAT REGARD.
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF.
THE MORE SYSTEM WIDE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN.
BY CS YOU THAT THAT LOOKS AT
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE PROBLEM
OF ACCESS UNITS AND COMES UP
WITH THAT. KIND OF PLAN.
WITH SOLUTIONS TAILORED TO THOSE
ROOT CAUSES BUT THAT THAT COULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL FOR THE SYSTEM
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THERE IS A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR CS YOU.
TO. TO USE THAT THAT THAT MONEY
THEY USE FOR COURSES YEAH IN A
MORE STRATEGIC WAY I'M REALLY
GETTING AT WHAT STUDENTS NEED.
ANOTHER STRATEGY THAT CS YOU WAS
IDENTIFIED TO IDENTIFIED SPEED
TIME TO DEGREE.
AND AND USE RESOURCES MORE
EFFICIENCY IS EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
TAKE ONLINE COURSES
FULLY ONLINE COURSES AT OTHER
CSU CAMPUSES YET THAT HAVE
AVAILABLE SPACE.
AGAINTHIS IS AN INITIATIVE OF
THE CSU REALLY AM AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY OFFERS
THOUSANDS OF COURSES ONLINE.
YET DOES SOMETHING WE LOOK AT
CSU DATA INDICATES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY VERY FEW STUDENTS.
ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL IN ACROSS
CAMPUS MANNER YEAH IN ONLINE
COURSES.
ARE REASONS FOR THAT INCLUDE A
LACK OF AWARENESS AMONG STUDENTS
THAT THIS
THIS OPPORTUNITY IS AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
AS WELL AS. WHAT WE WOULD CALL A
PROBLEMATIC?
CATALOG. ONLINE CATALOG OF
COURSES ARE THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS NOW CURRENTLY IF YOU GO
ONLINE TO THIS.
DATABASE OF ONLINE COURSES
STUDENTS CAN TAKE IT'S IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE AND
FIND A COURSES THAT A STUDENT
MIGHT NEED SO CSU IS AND. IT IS
IS REALLY GOTTEN A MESSAGE I
THINK TO TO IMPROVE THAT.
DATABASE IMPROVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS TO TO TAKE COURSES
ARE.
ELSEWHERE BECAUSE WORSE YES YOU
TO STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS.
TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO FIND IT
RULING TO GET CREDIT FOR COURSES
AND OTHER COURSES SEAT YOU
REALLY COULD IMPROVE STUDENT
ACCESS TO NEEDED COURSEWORK AND
REDUCE THE TIME DISAGREE.
SO I THINK OF.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WERE SEEN.
A LOT OF POSITIVE SIGNS A LOT
OF PROGRESS IN THE SYSTEM THERE
ARE ARE ALSO IN CONTINUE TO BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCIES AND A USE.
EFFICIENCY USE RESOURCES ARE
EVEN BETTER.
SO GIVEN THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REFORM GIVEN THE MANY OTHER A
COMPETING COST PRESSURES ARE
FACING CSU IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WHICH IS A LOT OF WHAT YOU TALK
ABOUT AN ISSUE ONE. I'M WE
RECOMMEND. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PLACING A LOWER A
PRIORITY ON PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR THE GRAD INITIATIVE IN THE
BUDGET HERE ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR
THE GRAD INITIATIVE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
AND AND AND CONSIDER.
FOCUSING ON SOME OTHER
PRIORITIES SUCH AS WHAT YOU
MENTIONED HATCHER MCCARTY.
THAT ACCESS ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
OKAY THAT I DO SO WE I THINK WE
SUPPORT THEM BOTH.
.
AND DATA CERTAINLY WERE WAITING
TO SEE WHAT THE. REVENUE NUMBERS
COME IN.
PAY YOUR TAXES PEOPLE.
YES
SO WITH THAT LET'S GET TO SOME
SOME DISCUSSION HERE I WANT TO
START BY BY OUT TALKING TO OUR
PRESIDENTS AND SO. I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS AND GOOD NICE TO
NICE TO SEE YOU PRESIDENT.
CASTRO I I THINK I REMEMBER YOU
LIKE TWENTY YEARS AGO AND IS
DOING THAT YOU SEE STUDENT
SENATE PROGRAM I DO YOU REMEMBER
THAT YES. IT IS I'M REMEMBER
HAVE A BLAST BACK HERE SEPARATE
THIS ISSUE NOW IS THAT YOU AS A
CSU PRESIDENT THANK FIRST FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO I RAZA A
NOMINAL FEE YOU.
THANK YOU BUT I REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS ON ARE. NOT MY STAR
WITNESS BUT HE'S MY A
CONSTITUENT HERE AND HERE AT
SAKS IDEA AND THAT. YOU KNOW IF
WE COULD I THINK IF WE COULD
JUST BOTTLED OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
AYE AT THAT SEX STATE AND SOME
OF THE OTHERS WE WE WOULD HAVE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY HERE SO
MAYBE PRESIDENT NELSON IF WE
COULD. TALK FOR A FEW SECONDS
ABOUT YOUR STORY AND AND
DIFFERENT FROM THE DAY YOU GOT
HERE THIS IS. A QUEST OF YOURS
AND WE SEE BY THE STATISTICS
THAT IT'S NOT.
JUST A FEW STUDENTS IT'S ACROSS
THE BOARD DEPEND COHORTS AS FAR
AS THE ETHNICITY AND. AND
BACKGROUND IF IT'S REALLY
WORKING. AND SO ON YOU KNOW WHAT
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS STRUCK
BY AND THEN YOU CUT TOLD ME IS
YOU JUST SHOW THAT STUDENTS AND
THEIR PARENTS WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY DID THEIR ORIENTATION. JUST
THAT SIMPLE MATHEMATICS OF.
FIFTEEN PLUS FIFTEEN.
EICHEL'S BECAUSE FIVE FOUR
YEARS AND TWELVE PLUS TWELVE
DOES NOT EQUALS THAT OF FIVE AND
SO A FEW THINGS AND ONE. ON
IT'S NOT JUST FIFTEEN OF COURSE
THEY COULD DO THIRTY PER YEAR.
AND SO I THOUGHT I I ASSUME THAT
YOU FOCUS ON THEY COULDN'T
SPECIFY THEIR FRESHMAN THEY
COULD EVEN GO TO. SUMMER SCHOOL
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR FREE
THERE IF THERE CALTRAIN ELIGIBLE
THEIR NINE NINETY NINE PERCENT
LIKELY.
THE THAT THE FORMER BOB
WHEREVER ELSE WAS THAT YOU DO
THAT OR THEY CAN DO WINNER
SESSION OR. OR GO TO A CSU
THROUGH ON THEIR THEIR THEIR PAL
FINANCIAL AID SO.
.
SIT SO CAN YOU TELL US YOU KNOW
HOW YOU ABLE TO.
MOTIVATES
AS.
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
REALLY GRASP THIS DECISION.
WELL I THINK THE FIRST THING IS
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN THE
STUDENTS.
AND I BELIEVE IN THAT SACRAMENTO
STATE AND ALL OF CSU STUDENTS
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT THEY
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AND THAT THEY
CAN TAKE THE CREDITS. I THINK
FOR A LONG TIME. WE.
SAID WELL TAKE IT EASY AT THE
FIRST OKAY TAKE TWELVE. PELL
GRANT SAYS YOU ONLY HAVE TAKE
TWELFTH PICK TWELFTH AND AND
WILL EVENTUALLY MOVING FORWARD.
WE'VE INSTEAD OF SAID TO THEM WE
WANT YOU TO GRADUATE AS QUICKLY
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN WE TURNED
AWAY THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
STUDENTS THIS YEAR. THAT WERE
FULLY QUALIFIED I WANT TO GET
THOSE STUDENTS IN TO THE CLASSES
BUT I'VE GOT TO MOVE THE OTHER
STUDENTS OUT AT THE SAME TIME.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE MY
STUDENTS.
LEAVING WITH DEBT SO WHEN WE
HAVE ORIENTATION WE BROUGHT THE
PARENTS TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST
TIME. AND I LOOKED AT THE
PARENTS AND I SAID. IF CARLOS.
MADISON.
ONLY TAKE TWELVE CREDITS.
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU AN EXTRA
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST TUITION
YOU GOTTA PAY FOR BOOKS YOU
GOTTA PAY FOR FOOD YOU GOTTA PAY
FOR HOUSING.
YOU WANTED.
IF YOU GOT AN EXTRA TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CHUMP CHANGE
IN YOUR BACK POCKET.
THE PARENTS ALL SAID NO AND I
SAID WELL HAVE THEM SIGN.
THIS PLEDGE THAT THEY'LL TAKE.
THEY HOURS THAT TAKE FIFTEEN
CREDITS.
AND THE FIRST TIME SIXTY SIX
PERCENT DID.
THE NEXT TIME EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS THAT IT
WHO AND I THINK THE REALLY
TELLING NUMBER NOT EVERY
STUDENTS GOING TO BE ABLE DO IT
SOME STUDENTS. HAVE TO WORK
EXTRA HOURS WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL OF THOSE
STUDENTS ARE YOU ARE YOU TELLING
ABOUT THE THEY CAN DO. THIRTY BY
GOING TO SUMMER SCHOOL WINNER
LIKE I SHOULD BUY IT AND WE'VE
INCREASED THE NUMBER WINNER
SESSION. COURSES SPECIALLY IN A
PROGRAM LIKE SOCIAL WORK WHERE
WE NEED TO GET THEIR.
PRACT HIM SOMEPLACE CS WERE
TRYING TO DO IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. AND.
THEY ARE SUCCEEDING THE THE I
THINK THE NUMBER THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T BELIEVE
WE WOULD REACH WAS THAT FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE FRESHMAN.
TOOK AND PASSED
FIFTEEN CREDITS IN THEIR FIRST
SEMESTER.
FIFTY PERCENT YEAH.
AND AS BEFORE AT MY NEXT
QUESTION AND IT'S REALLY. NOT
JUST THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
IF YOU COULD SAY IT'S.
YOU KNOW BETWEEN SIXTY AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT FORTY THOUSAND ADVERTS
SALARY FOR COLLEGE GRADUATE
THEREFORE GOING BY HANGING
AROUND THEIR FIFTH YEAR.
THEN IF THEY IF MAYBE THEY'LL
GET LUCKY AND GET A BEER G.
WAIVER BUT THAT'S ONE LESS I'M
NOT BE WOULD YOU EVER BECAUSE
SAHGAL STRUGGLES OVER SAGA WORK
BUT THAT'S ONE LESS AWARD YOU
CAN GIVE.
THE SOMEBODY ELSE AND SO. I YOU
KNOW I I THINK THAT.
.
THAT THIS IS A HUGE UP I KNOW WE
HAVE A BILL WE'RE TALKING ON THE
POLICY AS FAR AS WHAT CALIFORNIA
DOES TO INCENTIVIZE WHETHER IT'S
PALLOR CAL GRANT. STUDENTS TO TO
TAKE THIRTY OVER AT THAT THAT
THAT CAN'T CALENDAR YEAR NOT
COUNTY WOULD YOU CALL AGAIN
RYAN.
COLLEGE YEAR.
COLLEGE YEAR
I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU I I
THINK WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS IS
WHEN A STEEP YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
IT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO
LOST THEIR CRAFT CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY.
THAT.
OF COURSE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BORROW MONEY OR MAYBEGET LACKEY
AND GET A SAGA WORDS.
OR ON YOU KNOW FIGURED OUT BUT
THEY'RE QUITE A FEW WHO WHO RAN
OUT A CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY.
AND THEY PROBABLY DROPPED OUT
RIGHT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL AND SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE THINK AS FAR AS HOW MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE AND. MAYBE JUST
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION.
ARE MAYBE WITHIN THIRTY UNITS OF
A DEGREE BUT DON'T HAVE ANYMORE.
CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY OR FINANCE
LADLES BUILDING WE KNOW THAT IN
THE SACRAMENTO REGION THERE
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
WHO ARE WITHIN FIFTEEN CREDITS
OF GRADUATING?
THEY NEVER GRADUATED.
SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHY.
WELL FOR SOMEONE LIFE GOTTEN
AWAY.
FOR SOME OF THEM THEY GOT A
BETTER JOB ON THE LONG THE WASTE
FOR SOMEONE COLLEGE WASN'T
RIGHT.
THE FOR A VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PERCENTAGES AND WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT OUT AS PART OF THE.
AND INITIATIVE WITH LINE CAPITAL
REGION RIGHT NOW BUT FOR A VERY
HIGH PERCENTAGE THEY GOT TO THE
FIFTH. TO THEIR FOURTH YEAR.
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDING
IN THE FIFTH YEAR WITH THE CAL
GRANT.
AND THAT CAL GRANT MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE THAT THE COME. AND IF
YOU CAN'T PAY FOR YOUR TUITION
AND YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE YOUR
DEBTS.
YEAH ADDING UP YOU DROP OUT.
AND SO THAT'S Y. WE WANT TO SEE
EVERY STUDENT WE POSSIBLY CAN
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS. SO THAT
THEY DON'T GET TO THAT PRECIPICE
AND JUST SIMPLY GIVE UP SHARE.
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES AND EVERYONE'S
DIFFERENT YOU'RE DIFFERENT OTHER
PRESIDENTS JUST LIKE
PERSONALITIES IN THE PLAN SO GET
IT BE DIFFERENT BUT. WHAT WHAT
DO YOU THINK OF A COUPLE THINGS
THAT WE COULD DO AS A STATE AND
AND IT'S NOT JUST PICKING ON CSU
THIS ISSUE THAT?
AT THE UC LEVEL ON A COMMITTEE
COLLEGE BUT CSU IS THE WORK
COURSES FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
NEARLY THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE. I
THINK THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE IN
IN THIS WITH WHAT THAT FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS WITH YOU SEE.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT TYPE OF OP HE
IN MANY TAKEN ME ASKING OTHER IN
ANOTHER WAY IS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE COMPACT THAT STUDENTS
SIGN.
I'M REALLY INTRIGUED BY DON'T
THINK THIS MESS SIMPLISTIC TERMS
FOR US PEOPLE WHO GET A CREDIT
CARD.
YOU BUY NEW TV AT. SOUND SYSTEM
AT BEST BUY YOU GET A THING IN
THE MAIL FOR.
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ITS AS
YOUR MINIMUM PAYMENT IS.
FIFTY BUCKS
BUT HE PAY THIS.
IT'S GONNA TAKE YOU LIKE THIRTY
YEARS THAT YOU'LL END UP PAYING.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT A
FEW THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR YOUR
PURCHASE AND.
AND SO THAT KIND IT. GETS
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION SO. IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING WITH INCOMING CSU STUDENTS
AND HAVE THEM. YOU KNOW LOOK AT
THAT THAT WHETHER IT'S A COMPACT
A SIGN BUT YOU KNOW INFORMED
CONSENT YOU KNOW MAKE THEM
UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPLICATIONS OF.
TWELVE TAKING IT EASY VERSES
FIFTEENTHS AS A SEMESTER THIRTY
THROUGH THE YEAR AND GOING BAY
AND WHAT THAT ACTUALLY. MEANS SO
THAT FAMILY.
I THINK FINANCIAL LITERACY IS A
CREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
AND MAKING CERTAIN THAT STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A COST
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AND IT'S A
COST THAT WILL GO WITH THEM THE
REST THEIR LIVES. WHEN OUR
STUDENTS GOING TO MY E. D. YOU
AND THEY LOOK AT THEIR DEGREE
PLAN THEY ACTUALLY SEE HOW MUCH
DEBT THEY'RE RUNNING AT THIS
POINT HOW MUCH.
PELL GRANT THEY HAVE LEFT HOW
MUCH THEY'VE TAKEN OUT IN LOANS
SO THAT THE PHYSICALLY KNOW THAT
FOR AND WE NEED TO REMIND THEM
EVERY. DAY THAT THIS IS COSTING
YOU SOMETHING.
LET'S MAKE THE MOST OF IT. WE
HAVE A SLIDING SCALE IN
QUESTION.
YOU CAN TAKE AS MANY HOURS AS
YOU WANT ABOVE THE SIX AND
CREDITS AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PAY MORE IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE
PAYING FOR EVERY CREDIT SO.
THERE'S THAT INCENTIVE TO TAKE
ALL THE CREDIT YOU CAN WE NEED
TO MAKE IT EASY FOR THEM TO HAVE
THEM AND WE NEED TO NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THEY KNOW WHAT
COURSES ARE GONNA COUNT TOWARDS
YOUR DEGREE. THAT'S WHY SMART
PLANNER IS SO IMPORTANT TO US
YET. AND AND YOU'RE AND YOU'RE
AT THE PLATE THE PITCHER YOU'RE
MAKING IS THE ONE SEVENTY ONE
AND YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
IT WITHOUT THAT YOU'D HAVE TO
MAKE.
TOP DECISIONS CAMPUS WIDE PLUS
THIS PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BE IN
JEOPARDY AND HOW ARE YOU. MAKING
IT WORK THE LAST FEW YEARS TO DO
THAT.
THE.
THAT THAT THE GRANTS FOR SUMMER
SESSION.
THE.
THE OTHER EFFORTS THAT THAT
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO?
A FINANCE THAT I ROB PETER TO
PAY PAUL.
AND EVERY TIME I COULD POSSIBLY
DO THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN
OUR CAMPUS IS TO PROVIDE THE
COURSES FOR OUR STUDENTS.
SO A BUSINESS AFFAIRS ALONE GAVE
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR FROM ITS BUDGET THAT
IT WAS GOING TO USE FOR IN
FIRST.
TO BE ABLE THAT AUGMENT SO THAT
WE COULD HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
COURSES.
STUDENT AFFAIRS THIS WEEK GAVE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ITS BUDGET
AND TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE
ADDED EXTRA CLASSES SO OUR
EMPHASIS IS BEEN ON GETTING
THOSE CLASSES. OUR STUDENTS USE
TO HAVE TO CRASH COURSES AND
THEY WOULD STAY AND WAIT FOR A
SEAT TO OPEN UP AND THEN THEY.
JUMP IN THAT SEAT AND TRY TO GET
THE FACULTY MEMBER SIGN IN MAN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
HOWEVER IF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE IS NOT FUNDED.
WE'RE GONNA LOSE SEVEN HUNDRED
COURSES.
AND HAVE YOUR HAS HAS HAVE THE
STUDENTS IN.
SEE IF EIGHT AFFILIATE OF THEY
FULLY EMBRACED.
THAT THEIR REDIRECTION OF
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL THAT
MAKE THIS A REALITY.
I BELIEVE THE STUDENTS HAVE AN
AND KNOW THAT THE FACULTY HAVE
THE FACT WE'VE GONE OUT OF THEIR
WAY I HAVE OUTSTANDING FACULTY.
AT.
CAL STATE.
SACRAMENTO THEY THEY CARE. THEY
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
THEY'VE INCREASE THE SIZE OF
THEIR CLASSES TO BE ABLE TO DO
IT. AND THEY'RE TEACHING AT. ODD
HOURS I HAVE A CLASS NOW ON
SUNDAY ON FRIDAY AND SUNDAY IN
ENGINEERING. BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN
THE LAB WAS OPEN.
THE EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD
PRESIDENT GESTURE ABOUT.
WHAT WHAT ARE THAT?
TOP SPECIFIC THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW. WE COULD BE DOING TO TO.
NOT JUST THAT FRESNO STATE BUT
SEATTLE Y. AYE I THINK PRESIDENT
NELSON CAPTURED IT RIGHT. WHAT
WERE?
UNDER GOING NOW IS A CULTURAL
CHANGE WITHIN OUR SYSTEM AND.
THAT ACCESS ALONE IS
INSUFFICIENT SO THAT ACCESS AND
SUCCESS TOGETHER. AND WAKING UP
EVERY MORNING TRYING TO DO
BETTER AND BETTER AT SERVING OUR
STUDENTS AND. TWEAKING OUR
POLICIES INVESTING IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW ARE
WORKING.
STOPPING THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NOT WORKING BUT THIS GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FUNDING HAS BEEN.
CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS AND
WERE ALL MAKING DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ALREADY BECAUSE OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
CHALLENGES.
BUT THE FOCUS IS ON MAKING SURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS SUCCEED THAT
THERE ARE NO ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
AND.
AND I DO AGREE WITH PRESIDENT
NELSON IT STARTS OF BELIEVING IN
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE.
IT'S PROVIDING THAT EXTRA
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T ASSUME.
THAT THEY KNOW HOW TO DO THAT
WHEN THEY ARRIVE AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US AND I SERVE A
LOT OF FARM WORKER KIDS.
AND THEY ARE SO SMART.
HALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE VERY
VERY SMART.
BUT IF THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
STRUCTURE. THEN THE SIMPLE
OFFERED ADMISSION IS IS NOT A
COMPLETE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
PROGRAMS IN PLACE FOR THEM.
SO THAT THEY CAN SUCCEED AND
WERE SAYING THIS ACROSS EACH OF
THE CAMPUSES AND. I I'M
CONFIDENT THAT AS A SYSTEM WITH
YOUR SUPPORT WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE. TO ACHIEVE THESE BIG
AMPLE GOALS THAT WE HAVE.
OKAY.
THE STRATEGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. I BELIEVE ALL OF
US ARE.
.
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE.
THE INCREASING GRADUATION RATES
THE.
THE F.SIS ARE GREATER ACCESS
HOME.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
THAT GREATER ACCESS.
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
PA MY MAIN CONCERN IS THAT.
.
YOUR REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING GO TO THOSE GOALS OF
ACCESS AND.
SUPPORTING THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
AND.
.
NOT.
TO.
OR IT DID TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WATCHING THE.
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH AND
MANAGEMENT.
COMPENSATION.
THAT THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND IN
THEIR APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
STATE AUDIT.
WANTED TO.
REMINDS.
.
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS SAID THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THE.
STATE AUDIT.
FINDINGS WHICH INCLUDED THE CSU
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH.
IN MANAGEMENT POSITIONS THE
AMOUNT BEING PAID TO COMPENSATE
EXECUTIVES AND THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
CAMPUS BUDGETS.
AS FOUND.
IN THE WORDS OF THE STATE
AUDITOR.
THAT.
FROM TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
CSU MANAGEMENT AND SUPERVISORY
POSITIONS GREW MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE GROWTH RATE OF.
SERIOUS YOU SUPPORT STAFF.
THAT.
.
LED THE STATE OUGHT TO CONCLUDE
THAT THE CSU CAMPUSES COULD NOT
ADEQUATELY JUSTIFY THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL AND THEIR
COMPENSATION.
AND THAT AGAIN THE STATE AUDITOR
FINDING. THAT THE CSU CAMPUSES
DO NOT ADEQUATELY OVERSEE THEIR
BUDGETS.
WHICH REDUCE ASSURANCES THAT
STATE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT.
EFFICIENTLY AND APPROPRIATELY
AND DESPOTS TYPICALLY OF FAR
CONCERNS.
TO SUPPORT THE GOALS OF ACCESS
IN THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE SO.
COULD YOU ALL.
.
SOMEHOW REASSURE US THAT YOUR
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ARE GOING TO BENEFIT THE
STUDENTS.
IN TERMS OF ACCESS AND
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
AND NOT JUST TO INCREASE THE
RANKS OF.
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION.
MAY I.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ASSURE YOU
OF THAT.
AS I SAID WE PUT SEVEN POINT
TWO SIX
MILLION.
DOLLARS INTO ADDITIONAL COURSES
THAT MONEY WAS THE MONEY FROM
THE GRADUATION.
WE HARD SEVEN ADDITIONAL
ADVISORS THAT WAS MONEY FROM THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
WE.
CREATED THE GREAT.
I GRADUATION ECOSYSTEM WITH
SMART PLANNER.
THAT.
TELLS EVERYONE OF THE STUDENTS
EXACTLY WHAT CLASSES THEY HAVE
TO HAVE AND UNDERNEATH THAT IT'S
PLATINUM ANALYTICS WHICH TELLS
THE DEANS EXACTLY HOW MUCH WHAT
CLASSES THEY NEED TO PUT ON NEXT
SEMESTER. SO THAT THEY ARE
TAKING THE EXTRA HOURS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE THE
EXTRA CREDITS WE PUT THAT THERE.
.
I AM COMMITTED TO THE STUDENTS.
I KNOW THAT EVERYONE OF THE
TWENTY THREE.
CAMPUSES ID EVERYONE OF THE
TWENTY THREE PRESIDENTS AND OUR
CHANCELLOR ARE COMMITTED TO THE
STUDENTS AND WE WILL SERVE THOSE
STUDENTS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE COURSES
ARE AVAILABLE FOR THE.
AND I DO WATCH MY BUT BUDGET
LIKE A HAWK.
I. I APPRECIATE THAT HOWEVER.
LOOKING AT YOUR.
SYSTEM MY CSU BUDGET REQUEST.
OF COURSE THE LARGEST DIPLOCK.
IS IS FOR THE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND.
THEY ARE.
THE.
ADDITIONAL CSU BUDGET REQUEST.
ARE GOING TOWARD COMPENSATION
WHICH.
WE CAN UNDERSTAND GIVEN THAT THE
STAFF ANALYSIS THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE HIGHLIGHT THAT ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT OF CS USE CORE
OPERATIONAL BUDGET GOES TO.
EMPLOYEE COSTS.
.
BUT.
A AGAIN ME JUST FROM MY BUT I
AM SURE YOU CAN.
HIGHLIGHT
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
DOLLARS ARE BEING WELL SPENT BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE OVERALL
PICTURE IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE
LARGEST BLOCK IS GOING TOWARD
COMPENSATION.
AND THAT COMBINE WITH STATE
AUDITOR'S FINDINGS THAT.
THE MANAGEMENT A SUPERVISOR
POSITIONS MOE THAN DOUBLED.
FROM.
SEVEN TO SIXTEEN IT DOES RAISE
CONCERN.
I ADDS TO THE OVERALL PICTURE
AND HELP WHETHER THOSE DOLLARS
ARE BEING PRIORITIZE FOR ACCESS
AND THE GRADUATION IN.
ANY RESPONSE FROM THE SYSTEM
WIDER PERSPECTIVE RIGHT BE HAPPY
TO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE SEEN
THE REPORT THAT WE HAD.
DELIVERED IN JANUARY ABOUT A
PROGRESS UPDATE ON HOW WE SPENT
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR THAT WOULD DEDICATE OR
THE TOWARD THE GRAD INITIATIVE.
BUT IN THERE YOU WILL SEE
EXPLICITLY OUR GOALS NUMBER ONE
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
INCONSISTENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S TESTIMONY WAS THE
PROVISION OF ADDITIONAL COURSE
SECTIONS.
WE PROVIDED AT BOTH IN THE SIX
MONTHS THAT THAT STARTED FOR THE
ACADEMIC YEAR THROUGH JANUARY.
AND PROJECTED TO THIS YEAR AN
ADDITIONAL OVER THREE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL COURSE SECTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE CSU. ALSO IN
TERMS OF SERVICING THOSE COURSE
SECTIONS WE HIRED AN ADDITIONAL
OF.
FOUR HUNDRED WITH PROJECTIONS
TENURE TRACK FACULTY POSITIONS.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO BE REALLY
CLEAR ABOUT THIS YES A LOT OF
THE COST DURING COMPENSATION.
THESE ARE TENURE TRACK FACULTY
POSITIONS THAT ARE NET NEW. THAT
ARE ABOVE AND BEYOND WHERE WE
WERE IN THE LAST YEAR SO
THROUGHOUT TODAY'S PANEL AND I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR IT THROUGHOUT
THE DAY AND EVEN THERE ARE
PLENTY OF STUDENTS IN THE BACK
OF THE ROOM. IF YOU ASK ANY OF
US WHAT ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITY
IS ABOVE ALL IT IS ENSURING THAT
OUR STUDENTS GET THE CLASSES
THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
BUT DOING THAT TO BE FRANK TAKES
TIME. TAKES TIME TO HIRE THE
FACULTY MEMBERS TAKES A
COMMITMENT TO HIRING A TENURE
TRACK FACULTY TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT.
I'VE FROM OF THAT SYSTEM
PERSPECTIVE AGAIN REAL QUICK SO
I WANTED TO ADDRESS YOUR YOUR
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT THE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS SO.
LIKE IN MY OPENING COMMENTS AND
MENTION THAT WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES TO RAISE
COMPENSATION FOR ALL OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES BY ONE PERCENT. ENDS
UP BEING A LITTLE OVER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO WHAT YOU SEEN IN TERMS OF THE
REQUEST YOU SEE AN INCREASE OF
ABOUT ON AVERAGE THREE PERCENT.
OF THAT POOL ABOUT HALF OF THAT
MONEY GOES TO SUPPORT OUR
FACULTY.
SO THEY RECEIVED ABOUT A THREE
PERCENT INCREASE IN THAT IT'S
ABOUT HALF THE COST.
AND ABOUT A QUARTER OF THAT
ADDITIONAL COST IS TO SUPPORT.
OUR STAFF UNITS.
AND THEN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHER UNITS INVOLVED THERE TOO
AS WELL AS I'M WHAT ARE THE MPS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING OVER A TEN
YEAR PERIOD WE HAVE.
HAVE BEEN ON PACE WITH
INFLATION IN TERMS OF SALARY
INCREASES FOR OUR EMPLOYEES.
SO DURING THE GREAT RECESSION WE
HAD FIVE YEARS OF THAT NO
INCREASES AT ALL AND IN FACT WE
HAD FURLOUGHS JUST LIKE STATE
EMPLOYEES DID. AND THEN NOW IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM YOU
FOLKS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE
COMPENSATION. FOR ALL EMPLOYEES
I GENERALLY SPEAKING THOUGH I'M
IN TERMS OF YOUR CONCERN ABOUT.
COSTS GOING UP FOR EXECUTIVES
IN MP PEACE IN THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING ARE UNITS
HAVE RECEIVED ACTUALLY MORE OF A
COMPENSATION INCREASINGLY
ISRAEL'S NEGOTIATIONS AND THOSE
WHO ARE NON REPRESENTED SO I
JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT.
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING YOU I'M
ONE OF THINGS THAT AND IT MIGHT
THAT MY INITIAL POINTS I WANTED
TO POINT OUT WAS THAT. IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
PRESIDENT CASTRO IMPRISONED
NELSON CAN RETAIN THESE FOLKS
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM. A
SYSTEMATIC AND YEAH INCREASES TO
THEIR COMPENSATION OVER TIME
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE HAD FIVE%
YEARS OF A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
DROUGHT SO. WE JUST WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TO BALANCE A LOT OF
ITEMS HERE. ALL OF THE SPIES
COMPONENTS THAT YOU SEE ON THAT
LIST ARE REALLY KIND OF THE MEAT
POTATOES OF THE UNIVERSITY GOING
FORWARD. AND WITH A GREAT
INITIATIVE DOES IS ALLOWS US TO
ADD INCREMENTALLY MORE FACULTY
AND AND KEY STAFF TO THOSE
PIECES. SO THAT THEY CAN COME
BACK EACH AND EVERY YEAR AND SAY
OUR GRADUATION RATES ROTH OFF
THE HOOK SO TO SPEAK.
BUTTON THANK YOU.
IN THIS CHAIR I I'D JUST LIKE
TO CONCLUDE MY. MY A QUESTIONS
BY.
JUST EMPHASIZING THAT SO AGAIN
WHY WE DO APPRECIATE THE.
.
OPTIMISTIC SIGNALS THAT CSU IS
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
TERMS OF.
ACCESS IN IN IN IN TERMS OF
INCREASING THE GRADUATION RATES.
THAT THAT WE WANT TO AGAIN MAKE
SURE THAT THE DOLLARS ARE BEING
WELL SPENT.
TOWARD THOSE GOALS AND.
.
NOT NOT ON SOME OF THESE
SHORTCOMINGS AT LEAST IDENTIFIED
BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAVIS.
WELL I THINK IT'S VERY TOPICAL
OR HAVE THE DISCUSSION YOU KNOW
THERE'S.
WALK OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
DIFFERENT STATES.
BECAUSE OF EDUCATION NOT BEING
FUNDED. AND THAT IT IS A TRAGEDY
HERE THE DISCUSSION BECAUSE
WE'RE HAVING RIGHT NOW IS.
IS IT JOB AND THERE'S A STRICTLY
THE. THE TEACHERS AND PROFESSORS
COSTS OR DID THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COST
IT'S SOMEWHAT LISTEN DO I GUESS
SOME THE STATE'S DECIDE TO GIVE
THE TEACHERS THE REYES WOULD
WANT INVEST.
AND THE.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
I DON'T THINK. I TAKE IN.
FROM PETER TO PAY PAUL IS A
SOLUTION.
THAT'S NOT JUST KICKING THE CAN
DOWN THE STREET AND IS GOING TO
CAUSE PROBLEMS WHEN I HEARD.
HAS PRESENT NELSON TAKI WAS
TALKING ABOUT. WHAT TOOK SO MUCH
MONEY OUT OF HIS INFRASTRUCTURE
TO GIVE TO THE OPERATIONAL COST?
?
YOU MAY BE ABLE DO THAT FOR ONE
YEAR MAYBE TWO YEARS BUT THAT'S
GOING TO BE A RECIPE FOR A
PROBLEM LATER ON THAT'S. IN BE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
SO. I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THAT I AM STE.
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT SUPPORTIVE
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE C.
ISSUES.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
IN AS I MENTIONED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PEOPLE.
BUT I DO WANT US TO CONTINUE ON
THIS TRACK WE START FOR SIX
YEARS NOW MISTER EVANS NATHAN
EVANS YOU PRESENT DISH.
JEFF COHEN DESSERTS.
.
I READ GRASSO LOCKED.
IN THIS THING STARTS THAT COHORT
ENTRY YEAR.
OF.
TWENTY TWELVE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
ONE ABOVE IS LIKE TWENTY TEN.
AND THEN THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
AFTER SIDE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHEN MY READINGS IS ONLY GOT
HERS IS TWENTY TWELVE AND WE'VE
BEEN FUNDING THIS THING. IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS
FIFTY SIX YOU KNOW WHAT DOES
THIS TELL ME BESIDES NOTHING
YEAH SO I CAN PROVIDE YOU THE
DATA TABLES BEHIND IT SEE.
THE THE ACTUAL POINTS THE MAJOR
POINT HERE IS TO SEE.
AND WHERE WE HAVE BEEN ON
GRADUATION RATES THE TWENTY
TWELVE IS THE ENTERING YEAR FOR
THOSE FRESHMEN.
SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS YOU CAME
TO ONE OF OUR CSU CAMPUS
CAMPUSES IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWELVE WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU FOUR
YEARS LATER FIVE YEARS LATER SIX
YEARS LATER SO IN THE CASE OF.
THIS TWENTY THREE PERCENT
TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF THOSE
STUDENTS WHO CAME TO US IN
TWENTY TWELVE AS FRESHMEN ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. GRADUATED IN
FOUR YEARS OR LESS FIFTY PERCENT
OF THAT POPULATION GRADUATED
YEAH SIX YEARS ABOUT CB FIVE
YEARS OR LESS ED. FIFTY NINE
PERCENT IT SIX USER LESSON YOU
CAN SEETHAT THE LINES GO BACK A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE IT GOES BACK
IN TIME. THAT THE FIFTY PERCENT
FROM TWENTY ELEVEN AND THAT
FIFTY NINE FOR TWENTY TEN.
SO THIS THIS CRAFT YOU'RE RIGHT
IT'S NOT SCIENTIFIC THAT'S NOT
MEANT FOR YOU TO PINPOINT EVERY
YEAR I CAN PROVIDE THAT DATA.
THAT THE GOAL IS TO SHOW THE
TRAJECTORY WHICH WAS FAIRLY
INCREMENTAL FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
HAS REALLY SKYROCKETED UP WITH
OUR INTENTIONALITY.
WHAT WAS PROPERTIES I GUESS
SPEAK MORE TO IT A CONVERSATION
WE HAD LAST PANEL WE TALKED
ABOUT?
THE SOCIETY'S NEEDS FOR
EDUCATION FOR ECONOMIC REASONS
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEAR PERIOD
TIME BUT.
I DON'T SEE REALLY MEETS MUCH
OF.
.
WHEN OUR INVESTMENT HAS BLESSED
IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE SHOW ME LOVE
TO SEE A HAVE TO SAY THE OKAY
YEAH YEAH.
THE COMMENTS MADE EARLIER BY
FROM THE DYESS ABOUT THE AMOUNT
OF COST GOING FOR EMPLOYEES.
EVERY BACK MY OTHER JOB THEY
USED TO DO. RUNNING BIG
ORGANIZATIONS IT WAS. EVERY A
BUSINESS ACTIVITY LOOK AT AND
FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW IS IS IT
THEY MATERIAL CAUSES IT TO AND
YOU GUYS.
IN EDUCATION IT'S.
PERSONAL COST
BECAUSE YOU GET PEOPLE TO EACH
OTHER PEOPLE AND THAT'S A BAD
THING.
SO. I'M UP MY COMMENT IS A
EIGHTY PERCENT DOESN'T SCARE ME.
I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
APPROPRIATE I ALSO DON'T BELIEVE
TONE SOMEBODY HAD A SECOND EGG.
AND SO.
IF YOU'VE.
WE HIRE YOU TO RUN GREAT SCHOOLS
AND BARELY SEMI NUMBERS AGO.
.
NOW TO FRESNO YOU HAVE HILL
CHART TO.
I DIDN'T BRING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT BUT I CAN GET YOU SOMEONE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT TO SEE
BECAUSE YOU'RE FAT.
YOU KNOW YOU MADE A LOT OF NICE
WORDS BUT I'M MORE INTERESTED IN
THE NUMBERS SHADOW.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT FONG
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THE NUMBERS
SO WHEN I STARTED IS PRESIDENT
OUR GRADUATION RATE WAS FORTY
EIGHT PERCENT AND NOW IT'S
GETTING CLOSE TO SIXTY PERCENT.
OUR GOAL IS TO GET IT TO SEVENTY
PERCENT THAT'S IN SIX YEARS OR
EIGHT SIX YEAR REIGN. RICHARDSON
ARE TRANSFER RATE HAS GONE UP.
SIGNIFICANTLY AS WELL THAT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
SETTLEMENT CHARGES SO YOUR SIX
YEAR RATE.
FOR FRESHMEN COMING IN.
IS WHAT IS IS NEARING SIXTY
PERCENT NOW CHAU YOUR ABOVE.
WERE ABOUT THAT WERE ABOUT THIS
YOUR AVERAGE THERE YEAH ROUGHLY
THE STATE'S A FIFTY NINE SO YEAR
I ABOUT THIS ABOUT THAT AVERAGE
AND. OUR GOAL THOUGH IS TO GET
TO SEVENTY AND
THIS GRADUATION INITIATIVE WILL
HELP US TO DO THAT OVER TIME.
HER GOAL IS TO GET THERE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE REPORT
THAT WE HAVE ON PAGE EIGHT.
FROM THE.
I GUESS SHE LA JOH.
THE. AND TWENTY FIFTEEN TO FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE WAS
NINETEEN PERCENT. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IS TWENTY THREE
PERCENT FOR INCREASE OF FOUR.
WE'RE ANTICIPATING A GOAL A
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
AT FORTY SO IF WE INCREASE THE.
FLAG SLOW BUT FOUR PERCENT FOR
THE NEXT YEAR FOR SEQUENCES.
IT SHOWS WE GET TO THIRTY NINE
PERCENT IS THAT MY READING THAT
RIGHT.
DE LA OR WHOEVER PUT THIS
REPORT TOGETHER.
I'M PAGE.
EIGHT.
WHICH I HAVE ANNOUNCES I GUESS
IS STAFF ANALYSIS IS GENDER.
ON PAGE EIGHT.
AGENDA THEIR GENDER.
SO ONE SHOWN IT'S GONNA GET TO
THIRTY NINE PERCENT THE.
FRESHMAN SIX YOUR GRADUATE WAS
FIFTY SEVEN.
THEN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WILL GET TO FIFTY
NINE.
PERCENT
AND SEVENTEEN I WAS A TWO
PERCENT UP. IF YOU CONTINUE THE
GLIDE SLOPE. WE GET TO SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT WHICH SHOWS THAT
WE NEVER MEET OUR GOAL OF
SEVENTY PERCENT.
YEAH RIGHT.
YES SHOW ME WHERE YOUR LOOKS AT
THE TABLE THE BOTTOM HERE WHICH
IS AT PAGE EIGHT YEAH ON THE US
OF FOR WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
WITH TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHERE
WE'RE HEADED.
PROJECT THREES THAT WE HAVE WILL
TAKE US TO THE GOALS THAT YOU
SEE PRESENTED THEIR.
SO.
THESE GROUPS GET AHEAD SO WE
DON'T MAKE UP.
NOT SO THAT THE BOOK ARE YOU
LOOKING AT THE TABLE OF OF A
FRESHMAN I'M LOOKING AT PAGE
EIGHT.
UNDER SUBCOMMITTEE NEED NUMBER
TWO EDUCATION FINANCE OF APRIL
THIRD.
THE DOW THE UNDER BACKGROUND
GLOWED GRAPH IN THE BOTTOM SAYS
SHE ISSUED PROVIDE INFORMATION
INDICATING GRADUATES BEGAN TO
RISE ALTHOUGH SHE MAY GAPS AND
WIDE.
THE CHART BELOW SHOWS TO FIFTEEN
SYSTEM MY GRADUATION RATES
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RATES AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOALS. AND
UNDER FORT UNDER FRESHMAN FOR
pYOUR GRADUATION RATE IS
NINETEEN
PERCENT TWENTY FIFTEEN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS TWENTY THREE
PERCENT WHICH INCREASE OF FOUR.
AND IF YOU CONTINUE THE GLIDE
SLOPE UP YOU'LL GET TO A. RATE
OF THIRTY NINE PERCENT WHICH IS
NOT YOUR GOAL OF FORTY WELL I
SEE WE'RE SIX ANOTHER TO KEEP
DRAW LINEAR TRAJECTORY FROM THE
PROGRESS WE'VE HAD OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS OUT. WILL AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD POINT WHAT
WITH THE GRAD INITIATIVE THERE
IS CONSIDERABLE RAMP UP TIME SO
WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE. INCREASED
IMPROVEMENT IN THE OUT YEARS
WHAT YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT
TALK ABOUT IS THE COMPLETION
GRANTS THAT HAPPENED TOWARDS THE
END THAT HAVE HAPPENED BEFORE.
THOSE START TO KICK IN BUT NEW.
FRESHMEN THAT ARE COMING IN
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GETTING A BRAND
NEW FRESHMAN FIRST YEAR
EXPERIENCE ARE BEING.
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING FOR THE
FIRST TIME A CAMPUS THAT'S
WELCOMING OF THEM.
WHEN THEY COME AND IN NEED OF
ACTUAL PREPARATION IT'S ALL
THESE THINGS YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO SEE A LINEAR PATH IT'S GONNA
TAKE US TO THIRTY NINE YOU'RE
GONNA SEE A PATH. THAT'S GONNA
DOT THAT'S GOING TO BE JUST WHAT
YOU SEE GREATER GREAT AND THAT'S
RIGHT.
AND IF I CAN ADD IN THE TO SO.
IT IN THIS CURRENT YEAR AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THIS WAS THE
FIRST YEAR THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
INVEST SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE GRAD INITIATIVE.
OUR PLAN IS OVER THE NEXT THAN
FIVE YEARS TO ADD SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION MORE RECURRING TO EACH
OF THOSE YEARS.
SO YOU ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF
GREAT SUCCESS THE CAMPUSES RABAL
TO ACHIEVE STARTING WITH OUR
GREAT INITIATIVE EFFORTS BACK
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
AND YOU SEE THE MANIFESTATION OF
THAT. ENOUGH TWENTY FIFTEEN
NUMBER THERE OKAY.
AS WE WRAP UP WE HAVE. CURRENT
YOUR MONEY AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO YOU SOME MONEY EVEN BEFORE
THAT FOR GRADUATION A SHIP AS WE
PARK A LOT OF THAT MONEY.
IN THE NEXT HANDFUL OF YEARS
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME.
PRESIDENT NELSON PRISON
CASTERLY THE PRESENCE BRING IN
NEW STUDENTS THEY'RE TELLING
THAT NEW COHORT OF STUDENTS
TAKE FIFTEEN.
YOU CAN'T JUST LIVE OFF OF THE
SEVEN AFTER THAT CITY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WE INVESTED THE
SHAFT I GET I GET IT BUT YOU
KNOW I MEAN IT'S IT WAS AND WHAT
I DO HAVE READING MORE AND MORE
QUESTIONS BUSINESS WERE MA'AM
WHICH A PROJECTION IS GOING TO
GET. TO.
IS A BUT HE SAID IT'S GONNA BE
HARD TO FORBES AND GREAT WHICH
IT GONNA BE WHAT YOU THINK IS
GOING TO BE.
IF YOU HAVE A PLAN WHAT WE THINK
A FORTY I MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE
THINK WE'RE GONNA BE WE NEED YOU
TO NOT MUCH HIGHER THAN.
WHAT WHAT WERE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MOVE IS NOT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND YOUR LOT?
YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS RIGHT YOU
SHOULDN'T TELL ME A LOT OF WORDS
AND I'M LOOKING AT THIS AND I'M
SAYING IF YOU CONTINUE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. HAVE IN DOING TO
GOING ABOUT FOUR PERCENT THEN
YOU SAY WELL WILLING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO FOUR PERCENT WERE
GOOD ALL YOU NEED THINGS FOR TO
GO MUCH HIGHER THAN I DID GREAT.
WHAT NUMBERS ARE GOING TO BE
NEAR GO ON ABOUT ONE POINT?
THAT IS SO THAT TO ME LOOKS LIKE
SOMEBODY'S
TELL ME A STORY ALL I THINK THAT
I THINK THE DIFFICULTY IN UNDER
IN THIS IS THAT WHEN YOU.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STARTING
YEARS FOR EXAMPLE YOU LOOK AT
HOW WE SET
THAT.
SET REALISTIC GOALS BASED ON NOT
ONLY WHERE OUR APPEARANCE IT
SINCE ARE TODAY. WHAT WHERE THEY
WILL BE IN THE FUTURE THAT'S HOW
WE GOT TO THE FORTY PERCENT
FOR?
IN BETWEEN THAT WHAT HAPPENS
WITH COHORTS ARE GROUP'S AS RYAN
WAS MENTIONING THAT ARE STILL
AND.
THAT'S ARE ANY KIND OF BAKED AND
SO WHETHER IT'S FOUR PERCENT NOW
OUR THREE PERCENT NOW IS NOT
INDICATIVE NECESSARILY OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ART OUR
TRAJECTORY TAKES US TO FORTY
PERCENT. WE BELIEVE THAT'S VERY
REASONABLE AN AMBITIOUS COMPARED
TO OUR PEERS WE MAY BE A LITTLE
BIT NORTH OF ARAB CERTAINLY
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE. BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TARGETING ALL
RIGHT NOW. NOW WHEN I LOOK AT US
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I'M REALLY
ONLY SAY THIS FIRST WALKS I LIKE
SOME THE NUMBER YOU'D LOOKED AT.
FOR YOU SHE MAY GET PROGRESS I
THINK THOSE ARE VERY IMPRESSIVE
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
DOING THAT.
BUT I ALSO SO THAT'S A POSITIVE
NAY WITHOUT LET'S LOOK AT THE.
.
THE FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
GRADUATION RATE FOR YEARS AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN YOUR EIGHT POINT
EIGHT WITH THE STATE. WAS AT
NINETEEN.
IS THAT I MIGHT COMPARING APPLES
TO APPLES THERE ON THAT ONE
THAT'S TRUE. OKAY SO AND NOW YOU
UGANDA TO TWELVE.
WHERE THE STATE'S GONNA TO
TWENTY THREE?
AND THAT'S SO YOU HAVE A THREE
POINT TWO.
IMPROVE AND HE HAS A. STATE'S
GOING TO BEG FOR A HIGHER RATE
THAN YOU ARE.
.
FROM A MANAGEMENT STANDPOINT AT
THE CSU SYSTEM.
.
OBVIOUSLY SOME PEOPLE MUST BE TO
REALLY GOOD BECAUSE I SOME
PEOPLE ARE SO GOOD SO ARE YOU
MANAGING THIS.
SYSTEM WIDE OR YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUAL GOALS BY INSTITUTION.
YEAH SO WE HAVE A SYSTEMLIKE
COLDS THAT YOU LOOK AT HERE IN
EACH ONE OF OUR CAMPUS
IT'S HAS.
PICK CAMPUS SCHOOLS SO THAT
SLIDE I SHOWED WITH SADDAM STATE
BUT THEY'RE MATURE GROUP. THAT
THAT HELP TO ESTABLISH SIX
SCHOOLS BACK CAMPUS SO WOULD YOU
GO FOR SEGMENT RIGHT.
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
I WOULD HAVE TO I SHOULD KNOW
ENOUGH TALK MY HEAD. BUT I
DON'T.
SO.
YOU NOW BACK IN MARIN COACHES
SAY IF WE DON'T HAVE ESTABLISH
HOLDING YOU DON'T HAVE AN IT
THIRTY.
OURS ARE JUST THIRTY PERCENT
THIRTY PERCENT.
WE'VE BEEN A BAND AND IT'S A
SHAME AND THAT WHICH.
.
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY WE'RE HERE.
BECAUSE HE ALLUDED TO IT WHEN I
CAME TO SEX STATE THREE YEARS
AGO.
WE.
VERY VOCALLY SAID FOR THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN AT EIGHT
PERCENT AND.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT.
WE DID THIS YEAR THIRTY SIX
POINT TWO PERCENT INCREASE.
IN OUR GRADUATION RATE WE EXPECT
TO DO THE SAME THING NEXT YEAR.
AND WHAT WE EXPECTED RAMPANT UP
EACH AND EVERY YEAR. WE GOT A
LONG WAYS TO GO BUT WE CAN DO
IT.
AND THIRTY PERCENT THAT THE
REASON I DON'T EVEN MENTION IT.
IS BECAUSE THAT'S NOT MY
PERSONAL DOT.
I WANT TO BE AS GOOD AS. OR
BETTER THAN ANY OTHER CSU.
SIR I REALLY APPRECIATE WE DON'T
SOMEONE LEAVE YOU HAVE THAT
POSITIVE STATEMENT DE EVAN.
.
AND I WISH I COULD BE A THE.
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
AND I'M GOING TO BE PUSHING IN
THE REPUBLIC* ASSAULT TWENTY
FIVE MEMBERS TO VOTE FOR THIS.
I DON'T HAVE A VOICE ON BECAUSE
I AM GONNA REALLY BUT I AM THE
OLD GUY ON THE GROUP SO. I'LL
TELL I'M NOT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STATE FOR THAT
WE STARTED OFF DISCUSSION ON
EQUITY. THE VALUE OF EDUCATION
INVESTMENT WE MADE FOR SIX YEARS
NOT JUST IN CASE IT WHILE THE
CSU AND THE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE.
AND UC'S ASSAULT I WILL PUSH FOR
THIS I JUST ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUED TO WORK ON THESE
NUMBERS AND GO FORWARD. AND NOT
BECAUSE.
QUITE FRANKLY.
THE STATE. OUR SOCIETY OUR
ECONOMICS DEPEND ON YOU BEING
SUCCESSFUL.
SO THAT'S WHY TO ME AS I LOOK AT
THE. BUDGET ACROSS THE UNITED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A BUDGET. WE
HAVE IN THE STATE.
THERE'S PROBABLY NO GREATER
EXPENDITURE OF OUR RESOURCES
THAN FOR.
ARMED.
CAR PEOPLE DON'T BE ABLE DO A
GOOD ECONOMICALLY AND RAISE
FAMILIES TO BE HAPPY AND. SO
NICE TO LITTLE FRESNO AND BE
GREAT. LIFE'S GOOD. SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR DOING
AND I'LL TRY TO PUSH MY
REPUBLICANS TO SUPPORT
I THINK IT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE DICE.
SCENE NINE.
HER TESTIMONY AND WILL CALL UP
THE.
NEXT PAN. THANK YOU
.
WELCOME.
MORNING.
THE MORNING I AM A PROGRAM OF
THE DIRECTOR OF AN WOMAN
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AT THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
AS YOU KNOW THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
STATE BUDGET CALLED ON THE CSU
TO ADOPT POLICIES RELATED TO TO
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT TOPICS.
ONE ON THE REDIRECTION OF
ELIGIBLE STUDENT APPLICATIONS
FROM IMPACTED PROGRAMS OUR
CAMPUSES TO NON IMPACTED
PROGRAMS OUR CAMPUSES. INTO THE
PRIORITIZATION OF LOCAL
APPLICANTS FOR IMPACTED
PROGRAMS.
THE DEADLINE PRESCRIBED IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE APPROVAL OF THESE
POLICIES WAS MAY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES PASSED
POLICIES TO ADDRESS THESE TWO
ITEMS AT THEIR MARCH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MEETING.
THE POLICIES WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
BEGINNING WITH THE FALL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN APPLICATIONS
CYCLE.
DURING MY TESTIMONY ALL
DISCUSSED THE CONSULTATION
PROCESS WE USED TO CREATE THE
POLICIES AND THEN DESCRIBE EACH
POLICY.
AFTER THE BUDGET ACT WAS PASSED
THE CS YOU ASKED THE LONG
STANDING ADMISSION ADVISORY
COUNCIL FOR ASSISTANCE AND
DEVELOPMENT. AND REFINING THE
POLICY PROPOSALS.
THE ADMISSIONS ADVISORY COUNCIL
HAS BEEN A STANDING BODY OF THE
CSU FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS
ADVISING THE CHANCELLOR ON
ADMISSIONS ISSUES AND REVIEWING
SYSTEM WIDE ADMISSION POLICY AND
PRACTICES.
IT IS COMPRISED OF FACULTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND A STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE.
IN CRAFTING THESE POLICIES THE
COUNCIL HAD THREE MAIN GOALS.
FIRST TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
SET FORTH BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SECOND TO DEVELOP PROPOSALS THAT
ACCOUNT FOR THE UNIQUE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE CSU
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES AND THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY OFFER.
AND THIRD TO ENSURE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS HAVE A VOICE IN THE
ADMISSION PROCESS.
ALL NOW DISCUSS THE REDIRECTION
POLICY.
REDIRECTION IS A PROCESS WHERE
THE CSU SENDS THE APPLICATION OF
STUDENTS WHO CANNOT BE
ACCOMMODATED AT AN IMPACT OF
CAMPUS TO ANOTHER CAMPUS WHERE
THE STUDENT CAN BE ACCOMMODATED.
THIS POLICY APPLIES TO ALL CSU%
ELIGIBLEUNDERGRADUATE
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ADMITTED TO ANY CSU CAMPUS.
THESE APPLICANTS WILL BE
NOTIFIED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTEND ANOTHER CSU CAMPUS.
THE APPLICANTS WILL BE PROVIDED
A LIST OF NON IMPACTED CAMPUSES
AND WILL HAVE TWENTY ONE DAYS TO
INFORM US OF THEIR FIRST AND
SECOND CHOICE CAMPUS.
WHICH ENSURESTHAT THE STUDENT
HAS A CLEAR OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A VOICE IN THE PROCESS.
AS RESPONSES ARE RECEIVED
APPLICATION RECORDS WOULD BE
TRANSMITTED FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO THEM NON
IMPACTEDCAMPUSES. THE STUDENTS
WOULD THEN BEGIN RECEIVING
COMMUNICATIONS AND AN OFFER OF
ADMISSION.
APPLICANTS WHO DO NOT RESPOND
WITH THEIR CAMPUS PREFERENCES
WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY REDIRECTED
TO A NON IMPACTED CAMPUS THAT
STILL HAS CAPACITY.
THESE CHANGES WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT NO STUDENT MISSES OUT ON
THEIR CHANCE TO ATTEND TO SEE US
YOU.
THE SECOND POLICY RELATES TO
LOCAL ADMISSIONS AND IMPACT OF
PROGRAMS.
IN THE CONTEXT OF ADMISSION
IMPACTION OCCURS WHEN AN
UNDERGRADUATE MAJOR PROGRAM OR
CAMPUS RECEIVES APPLICATIONS
FROM MORE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
THEY CAN BE ACCOMMODATED. GIVEN
THE RESOURCES OF A PROGRAM OR
CAMPUS.
UNDER THIS POLICY EVERY IMPACTED
PROGRAM AT EACH CSU CAMPUS WILL
BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FIRST
PRIORITY TO LOCAL APPLICANTS.
LOCAL APPLICANTS WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
IMPACTION CRITERIA IMPOSED ON
ALL APPLICANTS
HOWEVER FIRST PRIORITY WOULD
MEAN THAT APPLICANTS GPA.
ELIGIBILITY INDEX SCORE OR OTHER
REQUIREMENTS WOULD RECEIVE A
BOMB.
PROVIDING A FINITE ADVANTAGE
OVER APPLICANTS FROM OUTSIDE THE
LOCAL AREA.
SUPPLEMENTAL IMPACTION CRITERIA
IS USED TO ENSURE APPLICANTS ARE
ACADEMICALLY PREPARED FOR THE
MAJOR THEY ARE APPLYING.
FOR EXAMPLE A FIRST TIME
FRESHMAN APPLICANTS APPLYING TO
BIOLOGY WOULD NEED A MINIMUM SAT
SCORE.
AND AN UPPER DIVISION TRANSFER
APPLICANT WOULD NEED TO MEET THE
MINIMUM TRANSPORT REQUIREMENTS
AND HAVE TAKEN CHEMISTRY AS PART
OF THEIR GENERAL EDUCATION.
CAMPUSES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
CLEARLY PUBLISHED THEIR FIRST
PRIORITY INFORMATION ON THEIR
IMPACTED PROGRAMS WEBSITE.
FIRST PRIORITY WOULD MEAN THAT
APPLICANTS GPA ELIGIBILITY INDEX
SCORE OR OTHER REQUIREMENTS
WOULD RECEIVE A BUMP.
IMPORTANTLY FIRST PRIORITY IS
NOT AN ADMISSIONS. IS AN
ADMISSION ADVANTAGE NOT A
GUARANTEE.
THIS POLICY BALANCES LOCAL
PRIORITY AND ACCESS TO SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS.
FOR STUDENTS AS ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS VARY THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM.
FOR EXAMPLE IF AN APPLICANT
LIVES IN THE LOCAL AREA CHANNEL
ISLANDS A CAMPUS THAT DOES NOT
HAVE AN ENGINEERING PROGRAM. AND
WANTS TO PURSUE AN ENGINEERING
DEGREE AT CAL POLY POMONA THIS
POLICY PERFECT PRESERVES THE
APPLICANT'S ABILITY TO ACCESS
PROGRAMS THAT OTHER CSU CAMPUSES
PROVIDING OPTIONS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
FOR FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
APPLICANTS NOT ADMITTED TO THEIR
LOCAL CSU CAMPUS UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL THE UNIVERSITY WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO INFORM THESE
APPLICANTS ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OPTIONS.
HIGHLIGHT THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER PROGRAM AND
ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONSIDER
TRANSFERRING TO A CS YOU IN THE
FUTURE.
IN ADDITION ANY FIRST TIME
STUDENT THAT WAS CSU ELIGIBLE
AND NOT ADMITTED BY THEIR LOCAL
CAMPUS WOULD HAVE THEIR
APPLICATION REDIRECTED TO A NON
IMPACTED CAMPUS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE DISCUSSED LAST SPRING.
HAS HE JANET NOTES YES YOU HAS
TWO TYPES OF IMPACTION.
WHEN I CAMPUS DECLARES CAMPUS
IMPACTION
LOCAL STUDENTS WHO MEET MINIMUM
SYSTEM WIDE QUALIFICATIONS.
WHICH IN MANY CASES MOST CASES
IS THAT BE AVERAGE AFTER A HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE.
THOSE LOCAL STUDENTS GET.
FIRST PRIORITY TO BE ADMITTED.
AND SO IN THE CASE OF OUR LA
CAMPUS IMPACTION NON LOCAL
STUDENTS.
ARE SUBJECT TO STRICTER
SUPPLEMENTAL CRITERIA AND SO
YOUR AGENDA PAGE FIFTEEN SHOWS
THAT THERE'S CURRENTLY ELEVEN
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE. CAMPUS
IMPACTION THAT AGAIN GIVE THAT
FIRST PRIORITY TO LOCAL STUDENTS
MEETING THE MINIMUM SYSTEM Y.
QUALIFICATIONS.
I CAMPUS CAN ALSO DECLARE
PROGRAM IMPACTION.
AND UNDER THAT SITUATION ALL
STUDENTS LOCAL AND NON LOCAL
MUST MEET STRICTER SUPPLEMENTAL
CRITERIA SO IT'S NOT ENOUGH
UNDER PROGRAM IMPACTION FOR
LOCAL STUDENT TO MEET. THE
MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE
QUALIFICATIONS
OFTEN THOUGH LOCAL STUDENTS ARE
AWARDED EXTRA ELIGIBILITY POINTS
LIKE A GPA BUMP TO HELP MAKE
THEM MORE COMPETITIVE.
AND THE AGENDA ALSO SHOWS ALSO
ON PAGE FIFTEEN CURRENTLY SIX
CAMPUSES HAVE DECLARED ALL OF
THE PROGRAMS TO BE IMPACTED.
PROGRAM IMPACTION ALLOWS
CAMPUSES TO ADMIT HIGHER
PERFORMING ON LOCAL STUDENTS YOU
THE STUDENTS THAT MEETING THE
SET THE STRICTER.
.
CRITERIA BUT THE POLICY CAN
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL
APPLICANTS WHO MEET MINIMUM
SYSTEM WIDE A REQUIREMENTS.
TO GET INTO THE LOCAL CAMPUS
THAT'S A PROBLEM A FAIR PLAY
SPEND.
SO IS MISS GRIMAUD NOTED THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AGREED
ON LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET ACT
LAST YEAR THAT REQUIRES A BOARD
OF TRUSTEES TO PROVIDE FIRST
PRIORITY FOR IMPACTED PROGRAMS.
TO LOCAL STUDENTS WHO MEET THE
MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE.
QUALIFICATIONS THAT LANGUAGE IS
ON PAGE SIXTEEN IT'S THE SECOND
BULLET POINT THERE.
THAT'S FROM THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
AND AS MUCH GROW AND NOTED THE
BUDGET AX ALSO REQUIRES THE
TRUSTEES TO ADOPT A NEW POLICY
ON AUTOMATICALLY REDIRECTING.
STUDENTS THAT DON'T GET INTO
CAMPUS THEY APPLY TO.
AND SO AS YOU JUST HEARD AT ITS
MARCH MEETING THE TRUSTEES
ADOPTED THE A TO POLICIES.
FROM OVERALL WE FIND THAT THE
RESULTING OF THESE RESULTING
POLICIES ARE A REALLY A MIXED
BAG.
WITH REGARD THE REDIRECTION
POLICY THAT THE BOARD ADOPTED.
LAST MONTH. I WE FIND IT'S IN
LINE WITH LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
.
AND THIS PROMO OUTLINED IT WELL
AND IN THE POLICY REALLY SIMILAR
TO WHAT CSU ALREADY DOES FOR SO
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER IT
AUTOMATICALLY REDIRECTS YOUR
APPLICATION.
SHOULD THEY NOT GET INTO A
CAMPUS THEY APPLY TO.
NOUN THE TRUSTEES POLICY ON
ADMISSIONS PRIORITIZATION ó
HOWEVER WE GET CAMP WOULD GET
GIVE CAMPUSES A GPA BOMB.
OR OTHER NATIONS ADVANTAGE TO
LOCAL STUDENTS
AND APPLIED IT TO ANY IMPACTED
PROGRAM BUT THE PROBLEM IS THAT
LOCAL STUDENTS WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECTED TO STRICTER
SUPPLEMENTAL. CRITERIA SO THE
POLICY FROM READING IT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO DO. WHAT THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRES WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR HAS
HAVE REQUIRED AND OF THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE DOES NOT REQUIRE
CAMPUSES TO GIVE LOCAL STUDENTS?
IT ADMISSIONS ADVANTAGE TO GET
INTO IMPACT A PROGRAM RATHER THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRES.
THE CAMPUS IS TO GIVE LOCAL
STUDENTS FIRST PRIORITY WHEN
MEETING MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE
QUALIFICATIONS.
AND IT'S AND IT REALLY IS
UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT.
.
FROM CSU HOW MANY PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY DO PROVIDE AN
ADVANTAGE TO SOME KIND OF LOCAL
STUDENTS AND HOW MANY PROGRAMS
AND STUDENTS WOULD BE IMPACTED
BY WHAT I WHAT THEY'RE PROPOSING
TO DO WHICH IS TO GIVE US. A
BUMP I MAKE SURE THAT ALL
PROGRAMS GET A BUMP.
SO THE LEGISLATURE HAS A FEW
OPTIONS HERE.
ONE OPTION IS TO ALLOW CSU TO
GO FORWARD WITH THIS NEW POLICY
ON ADMISSIONS PRIORITIZATION.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS
ARE SEE HOW THE POLICY PLAYS
OUT.
SEE HOW LOCAL STUDENTS ARE
AFFECTED AND WHETHER YOU SEE.
MORE STUDENTS FROM A LOCAL AREAS
GET INTO IMPACTED PROGRAMS AND
YOU CAN DECIDE IF.
THAT.
.
INFORMATION AND THAT CHANGE IS
SUFFICIENT.
AND IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
LEGISLATURE INTENSE.
ANOTHER OPTION IS TO DIRECT CS
YOU TO GO BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD HAVE THE TRUSTEES ARE
ADOPTED NEW POLICY THAT'S IN
LINE WITH THE. WITH THE LANGUAGE
ARE IN THE THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE. ARE AGAIN THAT'S ON
PAGE SIXTEEN. ARE OR YOU COULD
YOU SPECIFY IN STATUTE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT YOU WANT OF THE POLICY
TO BE THAT.
MAYBE IS NOT PREFERABLE BECAUSE
IS MISS GROWN NOTED IT IT IS A
COMPLEX SYSTEM AND CSU KNOWS IT
SYSTEM BETTER THAN THE
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE BUT. IF IF
YOU DECIDE THAT YOU REALLY WANT.
CS YOU TO DO WHAT THE LANGUAGE
SAYS THAT SO HE'S ALWAYS AN
OPTION NOW HAVE THEM GO BACK TO
THE DRAWING BOARD AND VOTE ON A
NEW POLICY AT THE TRUSTEES LEVEL
OR TO SPECIFY THE POLICY. IN
STATUTE.
BUT A QUESTION I'M NOT SURE I AM
CLEAR ON THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CAMPUS IMPACTION. IMPACTION IN
ALL PROGRAMS
RIGHT.
SO THE DIFFERENCE IS BUGS FOR
CAMPUS IMPACT SHOWN THAT IS
LEVEL IMPACTION SO THEY'RE
IMPACTED EITHER AT THE TRANSFER
LEVEL OR THE FIRST TIME. EGGMAN
LEFT.
SO THEY GET MORE QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS OUT THAT LEVEL THEN
THEY CAN ACCOMMODATE.
PROGRAM AND PACK SANDWICHES
IMPACTION ALL PROGRAM SO FOR THE
CAMPUSES OUTLINED ON THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE FIFTEEN. THEY GET MORE
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS FOR EVERY
MAJOR A PROGRAM THAT THEY
OFFERED THAN THEY CAN PROVIDE
ACCESS
SO THE FIRST ONE BEING FOR
FRESHMEN.
AND WORK DANCE FOR.
YEAH AND AND THE SECOND ONE IN
ALL PROGRAMS CORRECT.
AND JUST TO TO. MAYBE MAKE A
LITTLE MORE A CONCRETE OR
PERSONAL IF IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
FIFTEEN OF THE AGENDA. UNDER
CAMPUS IMPACTION YOU CAN SEE
SACK SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO STATE
NEW PRESIDENT NELSON WAS JUST
YOUR SACRAMENTO STATE HAS
DECLARED. PRO CAMPUS IMPACTION.
WHICH MEANS THAT IF YOU'RE A
LOCAL STUDENT YOUR COME FROM THE
SERVICE AREA AROUND.
SACRAMENTO NAY THEY HAVE LINES
THAT THEY'VE DRAWN WITH FREEWAYS
AND THAT SORT OF THING WHAT
COUNTS AS WELL AS A LOCAL OR
REGIONAL STUDENT. IF YOU MEET
THE MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE
QUALIFICATIONS.
AS A.
FRESHMAN OR AS A TRANSFER
STUDENT.
URINE AT SAC STATE AND SO GET
FOR IN MOST CASES THAT MEANS FOR
OUT RECENT HIGH SCHOOL GRAD.
CITY GRADUATED FROM. DAVIS HIGH
SCHOOL AND THEY GOT A A THREE OH
GPA.
THEY WOULD. THEY WOULD BE AND
THEY WOULD GET THAT GUARANTEE
THEY WILL GET FIRST PRIORITY TO
GET INTO SACKS STATE.
NON LOCAL WILL SAY STUDENTS FROM
SAN JOSE AND AND REALLY WANTS TO
COME TO SAKS STATE.
THEY WOULD NEED TO. MEET HIGHER
STRICTER SUPPLEMENTAL CRITERIA
THEY MIGHT NEED A HIGHER GPA FOR
EXAMPLE
TO GET IN.
PROGRAM IMPACTION.
TAKES AWAY.
THAT.
KIND OF A.
FOR LOCALS IT TAKES AWAY THAT IT
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY HAVE TO
THAT HAVE MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE.
QUALIFICATION SAYS THAT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH
HAVING MINIMUM SYSTEM MY
QUALIFICATIONS ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH
ANYMORE.
YOU NEED TO COMPETE WITH NON
LOCAL STUDENTS
TO GET INTO YOUR LOCAL PROGRAM.
SO. THE STUDENTS SAY IN SAN
DIEGO.
WHO WANTS TO GO TO SAN DIEGO
STATE AND I BELIEVE THAT IS AN
ISSUE? RIGHT WOULD HAVE A HARDER
TIME GETTING INTO SAN DIEGO
STATE.
THAT AND AT IN A STUDENT IN IN
SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S CORRECT AND SO IF A
STUDENT LIVES WITHIN SAY A MILE
OF SAN DIEGO STATE HAVING THAT A
MINIMUM YOU KNOW CHIEF GCR
CARMEN IS NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH
AND IN MOST CASES.
AND AND JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION. EVEN THOUGH THE
CAMPUSES ARE UNDER EITHER NO
CAMPUS IMPACTION WORK CAMPUS
IMPACTION DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE IMPACTED SO FOR EXAMPLE
EVERY CAMPUS EXCEPT DOMINGUEZ
HILLS BECAUSE THEY DON'T OFFER
IT. IS IMPACTED AND THEIR
NURSING PROGRAM SO I APPLY TO
SACRAMENTO STATE THOUSAND
NURSING AT MAJOR I STILL HAVE TO
MEET THE ADDITIONAL CRITERIA.
AND COMPETE EVEN IF I AM A LOCAL
STUDENT.
FOR A SPACE IN THE NURSING
PROGRAM.
WITH THIS NEW POLICY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING IS FOR CAMPUSES EVEN IN
NURSING TO GIVE THEIR LOCAL
STUDENTS A BOMB IN THE LOCAL AT
FROM LOCAL STUDENTS TO EXPAND IN
THE.
YEAH I KINDA MAKE IT EASIER FOR
LOCAL STUDENTS TO GET INTO
THEIR.
LOCAL.
RIGHT TO AN IMPACTED PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SAYING IS A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE BECAUSE IT'S IMPACTED
OUT TWENTY TWO OF OUR WHAT
TWENTY ONE OF OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES SINCE. MARITIME DOES
NOT OFFER NURSING BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT A CSU
STUDENTS IS THAT THEY ARE
SOMEWHAT PLACE BOUND.
CORRECT THAT THAT A STUDENT WHO
MAY GET TURNED AWAY AT SAN DIEGO
OR SALMON MEDINA. MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY.
TO TO CHOOSE TO COME TO SAKS
STATE.
AM I CORRECT IN THAT CORRECT AND
THAT'S WHY THE PRO THE POLICY.
ADDRESSES PROGRAM IMPACTION AND
GIVES LOCAL STUDENTS A FINITE
ADVANTAGE OVER STUDENTS THAT ARE
IN THE NON LOCAL AREA.
SUGGESTED.
CLARIFY AND MAKE SURE.
YOU GIVE THE EXAMPLE YOU GAVE
THE EXAMPLE OF OF NURSING AT SAC
STATE.
IF YOU READ THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ON PAGE SIXTEEN IT
TALKS ABOUT.
CAMPUSES THE TRUSTEES HAVE TO
ADOPT A POLICY WHEREBY CAMPUSES
PROVIDE FIRST PRIORITY TO IMPACT
THE PROGRAM'S TO LOCAL STUDENTS
WHO MEET MINIMUM. MINIMUM SYSTEM
WIDE QUALIFICATIONS
SO.
MY READING OF THIS ARE READING
THIS IS THAT.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THIS
A STUDENT WHO MET THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS SAY IT IT DAVIS
HIGH SCHOOL GOT THAT THREE POINT
EIGHT GPA?
WOULD GET OUR FIRST PRIORITY.
IN. SACKS STATES NURSING PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE.
.
AND THEN NONLOCAL STUDENTS WOULD
NEED TO MEET.
A REAL HIGHER HIGHER
REQUIREMENTS WHAT CS USE.
POLICY IS THAT THEY ADOPTED.
LAST MONTH.
WHAT THAT WOULD DO WOULD SIMPLY
GIVE A A KIND OF A GPA BOMB?
SOME SORT OF ADVANTAGE TO THAT
DAVIS STUDENT TO GET AND NURSING
PROGRAM BUT NOT NESTLING. ALLOW
THEM TO GO FIRST IN LINE.
SO IT'S ITS IT SEEMS TO BE
SOMEWHAT OF A DIFFERENT.
POLICY FROM WHAT THE BUDGET.
REQUIRES AND AND THAT WAS OUR
OUR COMMENT ABOUT YOU HAVE SOME
OPTIONS YOU COULD YOU COULD LET
THAT POLICY GO THROUGH.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS SEE HOW MANY
LOCAL STUDENTS GET INTO THEIR
LOCAL PROGRAMS YOU WILL WHAT'S
THE AND WHAT'S THE EFFECT OF
THIS WHERE YOU COULD JUST GO
BACK LEGISLATURE GO BACK AND SAY
CSU. THIS ISN'T UP TO SNUFF.
WHAT WHAT KIND OF IMPACT WITH
THIS POLICY HAVE ON A CAMPUS
LIKE? CAL STATE SAN LUIS OBISPO
THAT ALREADY HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST.
ADMISSIONS KNOWN AVERAGE GPA.
ALSO I A I THINK PROBABLY. ONE
OF THE LOWEST DIVERSITY.
ALSO OF CSU WHAT KINDA IMPACT
MIGHT THIS POLICY HAVE ON ON
THAT CAMPUS.
SO WITH THIS NEW POLICY ALL
CAMPUSES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
INCREASE.
SO SOME CAMPUSES ARE READY HAVE
SOME TYPE OF LOCAL PRIORITY BUT
THE INTENTION IS FOR THEM TO
INCREASE THE ABOUT THE BOMB FOR
LOCAL STUDENTS AND HAVE AN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF LOCAL
APPLICANTS THIRD BETTER ACCEPTED
TO EVERY CSU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL GO NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT
.
IT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S JENNIFER EGAN I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS THE TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OR SO PROFESSOR'S
LECTURES LIBRARIANS COUNSELORS
AND COACHES. WHO TEACH AND
MENTOR US STUDENTS IN THE CSU
SYSTEM?
US CFA CALLS ON THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE A
GREATER INVESTMENT IN THE CSU
THIS YEAR. WE ARE ASKING FOR
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
FULLY FUND THE CSU.
SEE A FACE PROPOSAL MORE CLOSELY
MATCHES THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND OF THE STATE.
SEE A FACE PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH THE
CLASSES THEY NEED AVOID ANOTHER
TUITION INCREASE IN BOTH OF
THOSEARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE TO
GET STUDENTS TO TIMELY
COMPLETION.
AND ADMIT AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND QUALIFIED STUDENTS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE TURNED AWAY.
AND AS WAS NOTED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE TURNED
AWAY LAST YEAR ALONE.
SEE IF A IS ALSO URGING THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT A BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING AT FOR
FUNDING TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF FULL TIME TENURE TRACK
FACULTY AT CSU CAMPUSES.
SEE IF THEY PROPOSES THAT THE
STATE SET ASIDE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF EXISTING ONGOING
FUNDS TO INCREASE THE HIRING OF
TENURE TRACK FACULTY. WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES ATTACHED
A AS TO HOW THAT MONEY WOULD BE
SPENT.
FIFTY YEARS OF RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT BUILDING A RELATIONSHIP
WITH A PROFESSOR IN RICH IS A
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE FOR
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR THAT
CONNECTION IS EVEN MORE
CRITICAL.
FACULTY MEMBERS ARE NOT JUST
EDUCATORS THEIR MENTORS AND
TRUSTED CONFIDANTES WHO HELP
STUDENTS NOT JUST COMPLETE A
DEGREE. BUT TO RECEIVE A TRULY
HIGH QUALITY AND MEANINGFUL
EDUCATION.
AND ON A SIDE NOTE IN RESPONSE
TO THE LA O. ANALYSIS AND I
APPRECIATE AND A MISTER STORM
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
MENTIONING THAT'S.
.
IT'S THE CSU OF FACULTY
RECEIVING SALARY INCREASES THAT
ACCORDING TO THAT REPORT WHERE
ABOVE INFLATIONARY COSTS. THAT
STATEMENT IS MISLEADING AND
LACKING CONTEXT
TAKEN ALTOGETHER SALARY
INCREASES FOR FACULTY MEMBERS
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS HAVE NOT
QUITE KEPT UP WITH INFLATION.
AND FACULTY AND I WENT WITH NO
SALARY INCREASES FROM FOR FIVE
YEARS FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND THAT'S
REALLY NO SALARY INCREASES
BECAUSE WE DO NOT RECEIVE STEPS.
.
WE REQUEST YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND SUPPORT FOR BOTH OF OUR
FUNDING PROPOSALS. OUT WE ALSO
INVITE THE COMMITTEE TO JOIN US
TOMORROW APRIL FOR A ON THE
CAPITAL NORTH STEPS SCFA LEADERS
STUDENTS THE CHANCELLOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AND LEGISLATIVE LEAD LEADERSHIP
ADVOCATE FOR A GREATER
INVESTMENT IN THIS YES YOU WORK
AND HAVE OUR AND A LOT OF FUN
AND YOU SHOULD COME SEE ARE
REALLY COOL OUR INSTALLATIONS
WORK AND HALF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LILLIAN
TAY'S AND I'M CHAIR OF THE
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
FOR OUR PRESIDENT GEN EGAN JUST
MENTIONED CFA IS FUNDING ASK FOR
THE CSU BUT EVEN THIS REQUEST
WON'T RESTORED THE DECADES OF
CUTS AND UNDER FUNDING THAT HAVE
PLAGUED OUR STUDENTS AND. OUR
AND OUR SYSTEM WHAT WE REALLY
NEED IS A DEDICATED SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WE ALREADY HAVE FOR K. FOURTEEN.
SO THAT WE CAN RESTORE FREE
HIGHER EDUCATION TO THE STUDENTS
OF OUR STATE TODAY.
A QUICK LOOK AT FUNDING FOR THE
CSU OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
SHOWS WHY WE NEED A DEDICATED
FUNDING SOURCES. BED YEAR IN BAD
YEARS THE SYSTEM SUFFERED
EXTREME CUTS BEEN IN GOOD YEARS
THERE WAS NEVER ENOUGH
REINVESTED IN THE SYSTEM. TO
RECOVER.
ACCORDING TO THE PP I SEE STATE
FUNDING PER STUDENT AS CSU AND
YOU SEE REMAINS WELL BELOW PRE
RECESSION LEVELS. DESPITE RECENT
SHIFTS OF HIGHER EDUCATION COSTS
FROM THE STATE TO STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
WE NEED A DEDICATED FUNDING
SOURCE BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
REALITIES THAT WE CAN'T IGNORE.
FIRST WE KNOW THAT THE STATE
INVESTED MORE MONEY PER STUDENT
THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN THE
STUDENTS WERE WHITE. THAN IT
DOES TODAY WHEN THREE FOURTHS OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE OF COLOR WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE ARE ON TRACK
TO FULL SHORT BY ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE MILLION NEEDED COLLEGE
GRASSROOTS BY TWO. TWO THOUSAND
THIRTY A HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE
TEACHERS WILL NEED OVER THE PAST
NEXT TEN YEARS.
THE CSU NEEDS MORE INVESTMENT
RIGHT NOW FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR BUT IN THE LONG
RUN THE SYSTEM REALLY NEEDS A
DEDICATED SOURCE OF FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
FOR HANGING AROUND FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT I'M JAKE PRIMARY WITH
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO OPEN UP TO
SEE IF YOU TO SERVE MORE OF
THOSE. HARDWORKING TALENTED
STUDENTS WERE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY'RE TOLD INDICATOR TWELVE
SYSTEM AND COMPLETING A THROUGH
G. AND BEING TURNED AWAY YEAR
AFTER YEAR. BY THE PEOPLE'S
UNIVERSITY OF THE CSU.
SOME QUICK BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
MATH FOUR YEARS OF MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS BEING
TURNED AWAY HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT WE ARE.
PUT HOPEFULLY SEEN GO TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE POINT
CAME UP THAT THAT MAY BE A LOWER
COST MEANS FOR THE STATE TO
OFFER LOWER DIVISION.
CURRICULUM TO STUDENTS HOWEVER
THE CAMPAIGN CAME OUT WITH A
REPORT LAST YEAR THAT SHOWED THE
DIVISIONAL CLIMATE TAKES FOR
STUDENT TO START A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND GET TO THE FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION RESULTS IN THAT
STUDENT FOR THE SAME BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PAYING A PREMIUM OF MORE
THAN THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO THE STATE.
IS REALLY PUTTING STUDENTS IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY WILL TAKE
OUT GREATER DEBT TO ATTAIN THE
SAME DEGREE WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THEIR COLLEGE READY AND ABLE TO
GO DIRECTLY INTO THE CSU.
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY NINTH IN THE
NUMBER IN THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ENROLLED IN FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT NOT ONLY
FOR SOCIAL MOBILITY AND TO
ENSURE THAT IT REALLY I'M
REMAINS THE VEHICLE FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY IN CALIFORNIA BUT TO
CLOSE THAT DEGREES GAP THAT I
KNOW. THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN.
LOOKING AT QUITE CLOSELY THIS
YEAR SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO LET
FULLY FUND AND FOR ALL THOSE
TALENTED STUDENTS WERE TRYING TO
GET THEM THANK. THANK YOU.
HELLO AMY MEN AS WITH THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ARE FAIR CITIES
HOW COOL ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE CSU REQUESTS FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE
ONE PERCENT ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND THE GRAD INITIATIVE THESE
FUNDS ARE NECESSARY AS THE
NUMBER ABOUT THE KNOWN ANOTHER
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
QUALIFYING FOR ADMISSION.
CONTINUES TO GROW CONSIDERABLY
YET BEING DENIED DUE TO THE LACK
OF CAPACITY FUNDS ARE NECESSARY
NECESSARY TO SEE FURTHER SUPPORT
THE INITIATIVE AND TO ADDRESS
THE GAP THAT YOU MAKE IT
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AHMED
HIM SPARKLES MONTH THIS SOME
WITH THE CAST A SITTING
ASSOCIATION AND A STUDENT AT CAL
SEPARATELY. ON THE REALITIES
THAT FUNDING HAS REMAINED
VOLATILE OVER THE YEARS AND IT
REALLY HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
BECAUSE I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT
WE'RE AND BACK TO PRE RECESSION
LEVELS. BUT DURING THAT TIME
BECAUSE ACTUALLY INCREASE
SO I A HAVE NOT EVEN AS WE HEARD
KEPT UP WITH INFLATION.
I'M I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE
PRIMARILY FOR STUDENTS AS WELL
AND I WON'T TALK LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT WHAT THE TUITION
INCREASE IN ON HOW STUDENTS ARE
THINKING ABOUT IT.
WITHOUT A FULLY FUNDED CSU. AND
AND WHAT THE TUITION INCREASE ON
THE TABLE STUDENTS MIGHT BE
FORCED TO PAY MORE. FOR THE SAME
LEVEL OF SERVICES.
ANOTHER THING ALSO WANTED
ACTRESS IS THAT WE HEAR THAT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE ACCESS.
THIS IS A BIG CONCERN BUT I ON I
DON'T AT HOWARD ANNUAL CHEST
CONFERENCE.
WERE OF OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS COME TOGETHER OUR
STUDENT TRUSTEES CONDUCTED
ANTIBODY WHERE THEY ASKED TO
DANCE ABOUT PRIORITIES.
INFRASTRUCTURE CAME IN FIRST.
STUDENTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HER
SAFETY RIGHT. WE NEED SAFE
FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO LEARN.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE STUDENTS?
BACK GET ADMITTED WHEN ACCESS IS
INCREASED.
DO WE ALLOW STUDENTS TO LEARN
AND CRAMPING CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THAT SAID I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE OFFERED EVALUATES ALL
THE PRIORITIES BECAUSE THERE ARE
REFLECT. OUR PRIORITY STUDENTS
PRIORITIES AND WILL BE STAND
BEHIND SO THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
FOR FOR YOU OUGHT TO CHOOSE THE
CSU.
AND IF BECAUSE OF FULLY FUND
THAT'S USE USE BETTER FOR
STUDENTS THE SYSTEM.
FACULTY STAFF AND A PRETTY MUCH
IS BETTER FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
HOW GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY AND MY NAME IS MAGGIE
Y. DEMOCRATS DO THAT YES HE
STANISLAUS I'M VERY PRIVILEGED
TO BE THE PRESIDENT? OF THE CAO
STATES DO ASSOCIATION AS A LOT
OF OUR STUDENTS HERE TODAY AND
THEIR RIGHT TO CSU SHIRTS. AS AN
ORGANIZATION WE REPRESENT ALL
NEARLY HALF MILLION STUDENTS OF
THE CSU SYSTEM.
AS I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CFCS EFFORTS TO
INCREASE STUDENT SUCCESS BY
FILLING THEIR FULL BETTER CLASS
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THEIR
PRIORITY AREAS. AT EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION THEIR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE INCREASING ENROLLMENT
BY ONE PERCENT MAINTAINING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DRESSING
MANDATORY COST INCREASES ACROSS
THE SYSTEM.
IF THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS NOT
FULFILLED. IF THE WORK AT THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE CANNOT
CONTINUE.
AND THE FACULTY AND SUPPORT
STAFF CANNOT BE HIRED IT IS
ALWAYS STUDENTS WHO WILL BE
HARMED.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
THROUGH A LONGER ROAD TO
GRADUATION WHICH MEANS MORE
MONEY OUT OF THEIR POCKET AND
THE STATE'S.
I'D LIKE TO FINISH BY SAYING.
EXCELLENCY REQUIRES RESOURCES.
WE CANNOT EFFICIENCY OUR WAY TO
EXCELLENCE NOR CAN WE EXPECT
STUDENTS TO DO THEIR BEST WORK
IN CRUMBLING BUILDINGS WITH
OUTDATED EQUIPMENT.
STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER AND SO
DOES THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF ISAKA MIGHT.
COLLEAGUES THOUGHTS AND THANK
YOU FOR STAYING AROUND TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT MANY WITH CARLA
CAMACHO I AM CURRENTLY A JUNIOR.
HIGH CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHICO AND I SERVE BOTH THE
STUDENT BODIES OF CHICO STAY IN
THE STEAM BODIES OF THE ENTIRE
CSSA.
AS A CIVIC ENGAGEMENT OFFICER.
I AM A DOCKET STUDENT AND MY
SISTER ALSO ENROLLED AT A CSU IS
ALSO A DOCTOR STUDENT. WE ARE
THE STUDENTS ARE TRULY TO DEPEND
ON THE STATE SUPPORT OF THE
CSCO.
BECAUSE WE DON'T QUALIFY FOR
FEDERAL AID WE DON'T QUALIFY FOR
PELL GRANT LOANS ANY OF THAT WE
RELY SOLELY ON CAL GRANT WHICH
YES WE DO QUALIFY FOR BUT THAT
BARELY COVERS. CAMPUS FEES WHEN
YOU LOOK AT MY CAMPUS FOR
EXAMPLE LOOKING TO RAISE OUR
FEES ARE KEPT SPECIFIC FEES
BECAUSE. WE FEAR THAT IF WE ARE
NOT FULLY FUNDED AS A CSU.
WE WILL FALL SO BELOW.
OUR NEEDED MONIES TO OPERATE
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO OFFICER
A TO OFFER ANYWHERE NEAR THE
SAME QUALITY OF EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS. SO WE ARE COMING UP
WITH WAYS UNFORTUNATELY THOUGHT
THAT REQUIRES STARTING THE
STUDENTS.
TO MAKE UP FOR THAT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY CAL GRANT
DOESN'T COVER MY SKIP A SPECIFIC
FEES SO THAT'S IN ADDITIONAL
BURDEN FOR ME SOME SHOOTER AG TO
PEACEFULLY FROM THE CSU. AND
STAND WITH STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF
AND MY SISTER THAT TRULY RELY ON
THIS
TO PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM
THINK YOU.
HELLO I THINK YOUR STICKER ON MY
NAME TO ME OR SOMEONE I AM ALSO
STUDENT ACT BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY SAN MARCOS AND
REPRESENTING THE CS IS A. GOTHIC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION OF THE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT OFFICER I'M JUST LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE CARLA CAMACHO I DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR ANY FEDERAL OR
STATE AID US ON THE ONLY ONE I
DO CONFERENCE CALL GRANT. AND
SOLELY RELYING ON THAT DOES NOT
COVER ALL OF MY FEET SO WE DO
URGE YOU TO FULLY SUPPORT AND
FUND THE CSU BECAUSE STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF A HARLEY REPRESENTED
IN THE CSU SYSTEM. STUDENTS FROM
MY PARK ON TO ALWAYS GET AN
OPPORTUNITY AXES GRANTED TO US
TO GO TO THE CSU INTERNAL HIGHER
EDUCATION COLLEGE OR FORTY
INSTITUTION. I LOOK AT MY LITTLE
BROTHER AND SEE HOW HE'S HE SEES
ME STRUGGLE WITH ABBY THREE JOBS
WORK AN AVERAGE JUST TO FULLY
SUPPORT MYSELF. YOU KNOW MY
BASIC MEANS AND UNCOVER MY
TUITION AS WELL ON THE AMOUNT OF
LOANS I MEAN NOW THAT THAT AND I
AM IN NOW. IS VERY HIGH AND
EXPENSIVE SO WE BELIEVE THAT
RELY ON THE STATE SUPPORT FOR
THIS NEVER THE IDEA TO FULLY
SUPPORT THE CSU AND FUND US FOR.
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF AND OTHER
STUDENTS HAVE WORKED AVERAGE SO
LADIES BEGINS TO DETERIORATE.
SEE ISSUES OF THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE FORM OF HIGHER PUBLIC
EDUCATION WE DO NOT DESERVE TO
BE TREATED LIKE SECOND HAND
CITIZENS WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
FLASHY YOU SEE TITLE THAT WE DO
HAVE THE MOST HARD WORKING
STUDENTS. THE OFTEN JUGGLE
FAMILY JOBS COSTS OF LIVING THIS
IS ALL ON TOP OF BEING A FULL
TIME STUDENT ODYSSEY ISSUE THE
AMERICAN DREAM IS NO LONGER AS
EASILY ATTAINABLE THE COST OF
LIVING ALONE CAN BE AS EXPENSIVE
AS TUITION. ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
CSU IS A GATEWAY TO UPWARD
MOBILITY CASTERLY HAS PROVEN TO
BE THE NEWLY THE NATION'S
LEADING UNIVERSITY BEHIND
ACCOMPLISHING THIS. VERY.
.
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS.
AND I WANTED TO JUST THOMAS'
COMMENT ON. COLLEGES WORKING
WITH CHANCE FOR SINNERS I
PERSONALLY AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT CHAIR. DR MCLENDON
CREATES ETHICAL INDIVIDUALS
WITH CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS
ARE PROVIDES THE ECONOMY WITH
THE PROFESSIONALS WE NEED AND IT
COMPETES WITH BIGGER
UNIVERSITIES. AT AN AFFORDABLE
PRICE AND THAT'S WHY I AM HERE
IT'S LIKE.
BUT YOU KNOW ASKING FOR MORE.
LOW MANY WAS ALSO MARGO'S I AM A
STUDENT AT HOW SILLY ALSO WITH
THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS
INCORPORATED.
I AM A GRANT RECIPIENT
RECIPIENT BUT JUST BECAUSE I
RECEIVE GRANTS DOES NOT MEAN I
AM WELL OFF WITH THE COST OF
LIVING IN LOS ANGELES CONSTANTLY
INCREASING ALONGSIDE. OTHER
BASIC NEEDS BUT SOME STUDENTS
AND SUPPOSITION POSITIONS LIKE I
MENTIONED MY TUITION IS COVERED
BY CRAP MY TEXT BOOK SIGNING
NEITHER IS MY FOOD FACED WITH
HOUSING OR FOOD
INSECURITY.
AND IF WE HAVE A TUITION
INCREASE WILL HAPPEN TO THE
STUDENTS THEY MADE THEY MAY NEED
TO TAKE LESS COURSES MAKING
UNDERSTAND THE CSU LONGER.
WE TELL PEOPLE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
GET A DEGREE PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND GET.
AND WHEN THEY GET THERE THEIR
FACE WITH LARGER ISSUES PLAN IT
MAKES ME THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF THE CSU HOW MANY MORE TUITION
INCREASES WILL WE FACE. AND HOW
WILL THIS OF A AFFECTS STUDENTS
OF COLOR LIKE MYSELF
SO I ASK YOU TO DATE TO PLEASE
CHOOSE THE CSU. THINK YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S MEDICARE'S I'M
ALSO A STUDENT OF CATHOLIC I'M
ALSO PART OF A ASSOCIATE
STUDENTS COOPERATED OF I'M ALSO
HERE ADVOCATING FOR I MYSELF AND
ALL THE STUDENT SINGLE PARENTS.
IN DANGER OF HOMELESSNESS OF
FOOD INSECURE AND.
LAWLER PROBLEMS IS.
ESPECIALLY TUITION INCREASE IS
THE FACT THAT. THEY'RE GONNA
THEY'RE HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
LIVING EXPENSES ARE HAVING TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN BUYING THE KIDS
THINGS ARE HAVING TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THAT AND WITH TUITION
INCREASE. IT IT BECOMES.
IT BECOMES A LOT HARDER FOR THEM
TO.
MAKE A CHOICE AND.
OVERALL IT.
THE BIGGEST FEAR FOR US AS
VETERANS IS THE LACK OF
ATTENTION I GUESS.
WE DO SEE AN INCREASE IN OUR
DROP OUTS FOR VETERANS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE IS SPECIAL
BECAUSE.
WE FEEL LIKE WE'VE DONE SO MUCH
ALREADY FOR THE COUNTRY AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE REALLY CHOOSE
TO GO TO COLLEGE TO BETTER
OURSELVES. AND BECAUSE ALL OUR
TIME TO CAN'T FIND WORK OUT
THERE.
WE ESPECIALLY HAVE A HUGE
NUMBER OF DISABLED VETERANS WHO.
HAVE RETURNED TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY CAN NO LONGER WORK IN THE
WORKFORCE.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE'VE
NOTICED IS.
THE LACK OF
SERVICES I GUESS.
THE LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
CLASSES CLASS OPTIONS IS DEATHLY
ONE SO SHE VETERANS WHO I'D
ATTEND THAT ARE RECEIVING
BENEFITS WE HAVE TO. MORISSETTE
PATH WE CAN.
WE CAN DIVERGE FROM THAT PATH WE
WE'RE.
IN ORDER FOR US TO KEEP OUR
BENEFITS WE HAVE TO TAKE CERTAIN
CLASSES AND IF THERE'S NO
CLASSES AVAILABLE. THE WE DON'T
RECEIVE THOSE BENEFITS AND A LOT
OF TIMES IF WE DON'T RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS THAT WE HAVE TO PAY FOR
TUITION OR. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DROP OUT OF COLLEGE TO GO
FIND A JOB BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
FAMILIES WE DO. HAVE OTHER
PRIORITIES.
VERSES OF MAYBE OF A FRESHMAN
STUDENT OR SOMETHING THAT MIGHT
BE LIVE WITH THEIR PARENTS OR
SOMETHING STUDENT INTERNS DON'T
WE WERE LIVING ON OUR OWN WE
HAVE TO PAY OUR OWN BILLS AND
EVERYTHING.
.
LACK OF LIKE I SAID LACK OF.
CLASSES.
WE HAVE.
KILEY AT CAL STATE LA WE HAVE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE FALLING
APART.
WE'VE.
I KNOW I CAN'T HOW WE'VE HAD
LIKE A BASEMENT CEILING TILES
FALLING OUT. HAVE FIX THEM.
WE HAVE WHITE BOARDS WITH NO
MARKERS.
WE HAVE A BLACK BOARDS WHICH I
DIDN'T THINK THEY STILL USED BUT
THEY DO KNOW CHALK FOR THEM.
.
EVEN THOUGH I'M I'M GONNA ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP AND I KNOW I'M
DOWN CITED I DIDN'T YOU. PUT A
TIME LIMIT BECAUSE I WANTED TO
HEAR FROM THE STUDENTS BUT YOU
HAVE STUDENTS BEHIND YOU AS WELL
YEAH SITE BUT ANYWAYS WE'RE
WE'RE JUST REQUESTING THAT YOU
FULLY FUND. THE CSU SO THAT WAY.
WE CAN RECEIVE THE SERVICES THAT
WE WERE THOSE VETERANS CAN BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR TUITION AND.
TO KEEP THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAUL INDONESIAN
THAT.
I PERSONALLY CAME TO ADVOCATE
FOR A C. ISSUES JUST BECAUSE.
.
I AM A PART OF A SMALLER GROUP
OF PEOPLE ON CAMPUS AND THAT ARE
PART OF THAT WERE EITHER IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM ADOPTED OR HIGH
LIKE A GUARDIANSHIP PROGRAM. AND
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GOLF I HAD
BOTH MY PARENTS PASSED AWAY
ABOUT THE MOST FOURTEEN. AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE I WAS
BLESSED TO HAVE MY GRANDMOTHER
IN SUPPORT ME THROUGH SCHOOL.
JUST LIKE MORALLY BUT ME
PERSONALLY I'VE HAD TO WORK
ABOUT LIKE TO JOBS AND.
I'M LUCKY TO BE LIKE A GRANT
AND SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENT BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF KIDS WHO
DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION. AND
DON'T GET TO GO TO SCHOOL AND GO
TO A UNIVERSITY LEVEL AND THE
FULLY FUNDING CS USE WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME.
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND GET AN
EDUCATION AND I THINK THAT IT'S
FAIR THAT YOU KNOW MOVING
FORWARD THERE SHOULD BE MORE.
FUNDING TOWARDS YOU KNOW
STUDENTS LIKE ME.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SENT
HIM HERE AND I'M A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE.
STUDENTS ARE ASKING FOR A FULLY
FINISHED ISSUE BECAUSE WE ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET INTO COSTS AS
WE NEED. I'VE EXPERIENCED THIS
NUMEROUS TIMES IN IT AND IN ALL
HONESTY IT SUCKS I HAVE TO TAKE
CLASSES THAT I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN JUST SO I CAN MEET THEM.
FIFTEEN UNITS A CRIME IN A
GRADUATE ON TIME I'VE ALSO GONE
COMMUNICABLE IS JUST SO I CAN
FULFILL MY LAST GENERAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT BECAUSE
CLASSES GET FILLED UP QUICKLY.
DUE TO NOT GETTING THE CLASSES I
NEED FOR MY MAJOR MY GRADUATION
HAS BEEN PUSHED BACK AS IT
GRADUATING NEXT YEAR ALL
HOPEFULLY BE GRADUATING
GRADUATING IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS ISSUE NEEDS MORE RESOURCES
TO OPEN MORE COURSES SO CURRENT
AND FUTURE STUDENTS DON'T GO
THROUGH THE CIRCLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MANUSCRIPTS INSECT NAM AS
SEEN FROM THE BEAUTIFUL
SACRAMENTO STATES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FULLY
FUNDED CSU BECAUSE THE BURDEN
SHOULD NOT BE PUT ON STUDENT
SHOULDERS.
STUDENTS ARE HUNGRY SLEEPING IN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OLD.
BUILDINGS AND COUCH SURFING AND
SUFFERING FROM ANY UNTREATED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
NOT FUNDING THE CSU ONLY MAKE
LIFE HARDER FOR MY PEERS THEY
HAVE FINANCIAL AID COVERED
STUDENTS WILL NOT FEEL A
DIFFERENCE WITH THE TUITION
INCREASE.
I HAVE MY TUITION AND FEE IS
FULLY COVERED YET I WILL START
MY CAR AND MAKE COLLEGE CAREERS
WITH TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
DEBT.
PAYING FOR COLLEGE ISN'T JUST
PAYING FOR TUITION AND FEES IT'S
PAYING FOR RENT FOOD CAR
PAYMENTS GAS PARKING BURKE
SUPPLIES AND THE LIST GOES ON.
A FULLY FUNDED CSU WOULD TAKE
THIS PART IN OFFICE STUDENTS
OTHERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN I'M A SOPHOMORE AT
SAKS THE. FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE SYRIANA POLICY ON THE
PREVIOUS TOPICS IN MY FAMILY GO
TO COLLEGE.
.
AFTER THIS I HAVE TO GO TO.
BIO CLASS.
WHICH YOU HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STUDENTS BUT ONLY SIXTY SEATS.
DOT AN EXAMPLE OF.
.
WHY WE PUT INTO THE CSU WE ARE
THIS GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS A
GOOD THING? I'M A SOPHOMORE THIS
IS ONE OF MY LAST YEAR COURSE
IS.
I NEED FORTY FIVE UNITS TO START
TAKING MY OF MAJOR CLASSES.
BUT.
.
IT'S PRETTY TYPICAL I'D SEEN
THAT I HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS IN THE CLOUDS IT'S
REALLY HARD TO. ACCESS FOR BUSES
AND ADVISERS SPECIALLY YA IN A
FEW OF THE BIOLOGY REAP WHEN I'M
WORST UP PUT ASSIGNED SEATING
SO.
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING DOWN
STRUGGLING IN.
AND.
THAT'S NOT.
THE ONLY CLASS THAT IMPACT IS
ACTUALLY A LOT OF THE NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTED. AND ALL
OTHER G. E. AND BUSINESS CLASSES
DATA WE NEED FOR THE FUTURE.
.
I ASK ALL OF YOU TRULY CONSIDER
FOR IT BUT IN THIS YES YOU DON'T
JUST TALK ABOUT IT AT EPITAPH
AND.
THINKING.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERONICA GARCIA
MARTINEZ I AM STUDENT AT HOW
SILLY.
SO THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
DEFINITELY HAS OUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE OF WHAT IT IS PLAN TO
ACHIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO HELP
STUDENTS GRADUATEIN A TIMELY
MANNER AND AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
OBTAIN A HIGHLY QUALIFIED
AFFORDABLE DEGREE. HOWEVER IF
THERE IS A TUITION INCREASE FOR
STUDENTS THE DEGREE STUDENTS
THRIVE TO OBTAIN BECOMES ON
ACCESSIBLE AND ALTHOUGH STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF WHO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID. CAN HAVE THE
TUITION INCREASE COSTS COVERED
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE WILL
NOT COVER NON TUITION EXPENSES
SUCH AS HOUSING FOOD INSECURITY
COST OF TEXTBOOKS AND OTHER
LIVING EXPENSES. IN ORDER TO
COVER THESE COSTS STUDENTS
RESORT TO TAKING OUT LOANS THAT
ACCUMULATES TO THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN DEBT.
WE ASK STUDENTS CONTINUE TO GO
THROUGH THE STRUGGLES BECAUSE
EDUCATION IS A PRIORITY FOR US
MANY SEE AS YOU STUDENTS HERE
ARE HERE TODAY TO SEE YOUR
SUPPORT IN HIGHER EDUCATION. A
FULLY FUNDED CSU IS POSSIBLE AND
CAN BE ACHIEVED.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS FOR YOU
GUYS TO SUPPORT US AND TO CHOOSE
CSU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M KRISTINE MILLER
I'M CHAIR OF THE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR THE CSU. AND
I DO WHAT I DO BECAUSE OF ALL
THE WONDERFUL STUDENTS THAT WE
JUST HEARD IT'S REALLY
WONDERFUL.
I'M I'M HERE THAT TODAY THOUGH
TO TALK ABOUT PHYSICS.
AND THE THE PART ABOUT PHYSICS
PART OF THIS WAS STEPHEN
HAWKING'S I'M YOU KNOW. RECENT
PASSING THAT THAT MOTIVATED US
BUT I HEARD RYAN STORE MENTION
THE WORD MOMENTUM THREE TIMES
TODAY. AND JEFF GOLD MENTIONED
IT AND PRESIDENT CASTRO MENTION
DEBT AND THEN I HEARD LOTS OF
METAPHORS LIKE RAMPING UP BEYOND
TRAJECTORIES AND GLIDE PADS
ALL THAT HAS TO DO WITH MOMENTUM
THAT WHEN YOU GETSOMETHING
STARTED. IT IT PAYS DIVIDENDS
WHEN YOU STOP IT COLD. JUST LIKE
AN OBJECT IN MOTION REMAINS IN
MOTION WHEN YOU STOP THAT
MOTION.
THE PROGRESS AND STE AND THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WITHOUT FULL FUNDING.
SO WHEN I HEAR FOR INSTANCE FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAY THAT WE SHOULDN'T FIND THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE THAT
DEFIES LOGIC TO ME.
WHEN I HEAR THE GOVERNOR SAY WE
SHOULD GIVE THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO THE CSU AND TO THE UC THAT
DEFIES LOGIC TO ME IT DEFIES
PHYSICS.
SO WE NEED TO KEEP UP THE
MOMENTUM WITH FULL FUNDING OF
THE CSU IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE ALL
OF IT THE WONDERFUL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISS MEDINA MARK A.
STAFF.
DAVID BELL HAWKINS WITH THE CSU
EMPLOYEES UNION OUT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A.
.
UNIQUE REQUEST THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP WITH STAFFING
AND.
IMPROVING THE CLIMATE FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
FACULTY STUDENTS AND OUT AND IN
AND ALSO AS A SUPPORT STAFF.
WE'VE HAD A CHEMICAL SPILLS
INTO CLEAN THE BY JANITORS
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF HAS MANY
QUIT MEANT WE HAVE LED THE WATER
IS ACT STATE THAT WAS THERE FOR
TEN MINUTES BEFORE THE CAMPUS
WAS HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED.
THERE'S A DOES STATE ART IT'S
GOOD NEWS.
BE PUBLISHED AND I WERE TOLD BY
THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH IS GOING TO COME
UNDER.
ATTACK QUITE A BIT HARSH
CRITICISM FOR THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW AND SO
WE DOOR ASKING FOR SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP WITH
THAT PURPOSE.
IKEA THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS WITH
THE FAA IN CS YOU YOU. AND.
FULLY FUNDING CSU AND AUGMENT
BUDGET FOR THE CSU TO AT LEAST
AT A BARE MINIMUM BREAK EVEN
THIS YEAR RATHER THAN TAKE A
DEFICIT.
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A NEED
FOR A LARGER CONVERSATION ON HOW
WE CAN TO TO FULLY FUND THE CSU
AND ADDRESSES STUDENT GROWTH. UP
PARTICULARLY WE ARE.
SUPPORTING THEIR ASK FOR THE
WORKPLACE SAFETY SEVEN FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION MCF
PHASE REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR
TENURE.
A STABLE FACULTY IS THE BEST
WAY FOR STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESS AND HAVE SOMEONE TO GO
TO NOT ONLY AS A TEACHER BUT AS
A MENTOR IN HERE THINK YOU THANK
YOU.
AND SEE NO OTHER.
PUBLIC.
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE AGAIN AND
ESPECIALLY THE STUDENTS WERE
TAKING THEIR TIME OUT OF THEIR
BUSY SCHEDULES TO COME IN HERE.
IT'S THAT IMPORTANT WHAT YOU DO
STUDENTS.
ROGER